speaking at a news conference in tokyo
president joe biden said that the u.s
would intervene with military might
should china invade taiwan effectively
ending
the uh us
one china policy our ambiguous stance on
whether or not we recognize taiwan china
of course is pissed off and uh i i don't
know if this was a powerful statement
from a strong president saying i am
issuing a red line or a gaffe from an
absent-minded broken brained president
who is gaffing us towards world war iii
considering
even his own administration is walking
things back and the press is trying to
cover up for what he said it seems like
joe biden is just gaffing us into world
war three so we'll definitely have to
talk about that and uh the potential
risks involved i think error on the side
of gaf with this guy for sure i think
china knows that we want to defend
taiwan you know it's just like now it's
out in the open i guess maybe it'll give
china some excuses in negotiating power
we also have a gas once again at record
highs a diesel shortage joe biden wants
to tap into the strategic diesel
reserves because things are just not
looking that good monkey pox yep that's
a thing i guess and donald trump
re-truth which that's what it's called
when you share a truth on truth social
he retrieved civil war
and then the media got went nuts and
they were like donald trump is calling
for civil war this is irresponsible
and then you just need to google the
word civil war to see every leftist
saying it's coming or it's already
happening so we have robert rice who's
like the second second civil war is
already happening but they only get mad
when trump says it and then all of a
sudden they act like they never claimed
it was coming so we will talk about all
of that as well as transhumanism
joining us to discuss that is joe allen
hi there
very wonderful to be here joe allen i
cover transhumanism at the war room with
steve bannon where we are fomenting the
revolt against the modern world
uh i also write for a number of
publications the federalist salvo
magazine chronicles magazine among
others cool well we should definitely
talk about transhumanism i love talking
about that stuff so we'll get into all
that thanks for coming you got jim sham
i'm seamus coughlin i run freedom tunes
we actually have several videos coming
out this week so go over there subscribe
hit the notification bell also on may
30th we are going to be officially
launching the website so go over to
freedomtunes.com put your email address
in and you'll be notified when we're up
i uh what's up everybody ian crossland
over here
i just came across the country and let
me tell you i got a taste of that gas
price thing you crossed the land yeah i
did i crossed the land
i brought it back sheamus right here
with you uh man that gas five dollar
gallons that's no joke it's another
reality man it's like every time you go
to the pump it's just doing the kalima
thing where it rips your heart out oh
geez
i'm back and i brought it with me oh man
we have a we have a truck that runs on
diesel because you know sometimes we
gotta pull the trailer with it and just
i'm like let's not use that for the time
being unless we absolutely have to
so now it's just you know we need to go
find some
junk used electric car or something yeah
yeah it dipped for a little while you
know the price of gasoline did go down
for a little bit i was hoping that uh it
was gonna yeah well i i figured it would
probably end up going back up but not
this quickly well i have bad news i
think that the reason it dipped was
because they lifted that gas tax and
that goes back into effect in a couple
weeks and uh they say that gas could
rise by 30 cents overnight so that's
really freaking exciting i'm thrilled
about that the price of plane tickets is
going up as well we notice that with
your trip kind of sucks anyway i'm here
too pushing buttons i got a message from
luke rutkowski said he was he's like i'm
going to come back soon so everyone can
just you know tweet at him and let them
know how much they love him and how much
he should come back i think he's gonna
end up walking yeah he might yeah
with these prices are you kidding me
yeah cause he's driving diesel yeah yeah
it's like it's gonna be six bucks by
august we'll get it we'll get into that
before we get started ladies and
gentlemen head over to timcast.com
become a member to help support our work
as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from this show monday
through thursday at 11 p.m we'll have a
pretty good one up tonight at 11 pm as i
said and uh you'll be supporting our
journalists we've got a couple new
people who are going to be coming out
soon potentially hiring more uh
reporters so we can start doing better
and better work for you guys and uh
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends now let's get into
that first big story
joe biden says the us would intervene
with military to defend taiwan
the ap reports president joe biden said
monday the u.s would intervene
militarily if china were to invade
taiwan declaring the commitment to
protect the island is even stronger
after russia's invasion of ukraine quote
as i'm quoting the ap here it was one of
the most forceful presidential
statements in support of taiwan's
self-governing in decades
wow
talk about strength from our leader joe
biden
in fact so strong that bloomberg reports
biden misspeaks on taiwan
says u.s military would intervene oh
you know i love
they they're they try to cover for him
so much they don't know which direction
to go so the ap is like what a forceful
statement like no he was gaffing and
then bloomberg is like he was
misspeaking yo he literally said one
word yes he was asked would the us use
military uh interviewing with military
to defend taiwan from china and biden
goes yes and there and then the report
was like
really
wow yeah okay everyone was surprised joe
biden just came out and just said that
effectively ending
multi-decade-long uh policy on how the
u.s approaches china and basically just
telling china to go screw up so
look if if if someone who was
cognitively uh
functioning said yes i'd be like whoa
but i think what really happened is we
know the us does want to intervene with
military in the event china invades
taiwan but nobody's going to come out
and say it but you know joe biden is sun
setting so it's like it's getting late
in the day and he's like
and then they say it he just his
filter's off yes
and then immediately an unnamed white
house official walks it back saying
that's not true we wouldn't do this and
we we have the one china policy that
hasn't changed i see all this reporting
coming from cnn and these these these
reporters coming up being like the white
house actually says and then i'm like
who
who
cnn comes out and covers for the
president it's not true he didn't mean
it bloomberg covers for the president
saying he was misspeaking and the ap
covers for the president saying it was a
truly forceful statement
yeah we're gaffing towards world war
three and just
it's almost like it's dangerous to have
a nice by the way it's almost like it's
dangerous to have a president who's
experiencing cognitive decline you know
i think there's only one way to bring
this administration back and that's for
joe biden to become the first celebrity
endorsement of neurolink
once that happens
then we can go forward and of course
you know as much as i oppose pretty much
everything that elon musk is about aside
from this free speech and the chicks uh
i think that um you know he would
probably bring it back around if he
could tweak the neural link to start
making biden say ridiculous things more
ridiculous things than he does now for
instance if he could have him turn to
nancy pelosi and say that your your hair
looks like it smells so delicious yeah
come on man i smelled dance's hair ah
but i i agree like if there's anybody
who should get neural and gets joe biden
he needs some kind the upper is clearly
not working anymore maybe this is the uh
kind of like the missing footage from
idiocracy you know before everything
goes down world war three wipes out all
the rest of the smart people due to some
re ridiculous president no no we all get
on elon musk's starship and leave
how many people can that thing hold do
we know
no i don't know anything about it no
starship let's find that starship for
like a mars colony or something you guys
enjoy
no well i mean if the earth is about to
explode yeah absolutely i was thinking
mars has like what a third of earth's
gravity oh mars can't sustain it
that's what's that gonna what's going to
do underground
let's go well the issue is mars my
understanding it doesn't have an
atmosphere so we'd be living in domes
like you know biodome like with paulie
shawarma or that movie oh yeah you know
steve bannon worked on the original
biodome
like the real one yep
absolutely in the real world not the
polly shore movie no the real one in the
real world okay uh it's it's it's
fascinating
i just saw an article about quantum uh
some sort of quantum telescopes that can
check underground and like map the
underground now all the caverns and
stuff so maybe we'll do that on mars
i was just thinking about biden a couple
days ago was back at my parents house
kind of off the off the internet
thinking like
if you have a military commander that's
incompetent or that's losing his mind or
her mind you need to replace them
immediately with with another form of
command
unfortunately the president's a little
awkward situation because it's not like
a general you're you're a commanding
general um but i would be so much
happier with kamal harris running the
show right now because he's not stable
no no she's an ai auto predict tech spot
i mean we it's funny because it's a joke
because of like a few gaps she's had but
when you really look at what she said it
it she's not speaking it's like she sits
down
and she's imagining what's going on in
her head as she's being interviewed and
she's like don't screw up don't screw up
say words say words you did it those are
words and she's not actually telling
anybody anything she's like as the vice
president you have to be vice
presidential to be the vice president on
a vice presidential mission for the vice
president you're like okay okay what
well say what you want the woman stands
for freedom she does that that's true
yeah i was looking at you waiting for to
use that one yeah no no no
it's it's it's the oh yeah you're right
i wrote that a couple days ago i was
like i hope i can say this on tim cast i
was looking at the the succession the
other day and um you know one hard bout
of covid or maybe monkey pox at this
point and uh you would take out biden
pelosi and i think it's leahey
and then boom you're left with harris
and blinken
imagine a world like that that's
probably why they're so worried about
every new thing that's popping up
because they're i mean let's be real
like kovid was it was primarily hitting
older people even bill gates says so so
naturally yeah they were freaking out
it's probably why nancy pelosi was like
everyone's got to wear mess no matter
what because she's in the affected group
that means what is she 80 yeah yeah she
that's like the highest bracket for
covid so and joe biden too i mean
seriously though look we don't want
anybody getting sick or anything but
like you can't you can't freak out or i
should put it this way it goes to show
why it is really dangerous to have these
elderly
oh yeah octogenarians yeah
82.
they just won't
you know they they've like gripped onto
power and they won't let it go they're
like those things on ship's holes it's
like gollum barnacles they're they're
all barnacles we're stuck with them i
i'd imagine congress is more like a
bunch of gollum from lord of the rings
you know they want the power they won't
give it up they're all like their teeth
have fallen out and their hair is gone i
mean
i'm not kidding the comparison holds up
it feels so intricately entrenched like
i'm very concerned about how to fix the
situation with the united states because
i'm like the corporations don't own us
we own corporations the united states
are people sovereign and people on
twitter are like no the corporations own
us ian and like come on purge the black
pill we can take control but like
they're so entrenched these these 80
year old billionaires or millionaires
with these people that are like klaus i
don't know how tight nancy pelosi and
cloud schwab are i'm just using names
right now but people that are like
multi-national bankers are tight with
these 80 year old politicians and
they've been tight for like 30 years how
do you destroy or disrupt that web
how would you disrupt that web is it
technological is this the where the the
the future of technology is headed you
know that's a hard question to throw at
me right away how do you fix it all uh
do you do with technology give us the
answers otherwise you don't have
credibility yeah um you know i have a
answer but i think that most of our
solutions lie regionally locally i i
don't think that um any mass movement is
necessarily going to stop
this this corporate technocratic
takeover that we've seen really arguably
since the 60s people put the date
different places uh and it does have
such a momentum at this point that uh to
me
i think the notion of just stopping it
like a train is pretty ridiculous i
think that the the best options we have
right now lie with ourselves it's very
unwise to look to a higher earthly power
for salvation in this situation
yeah well i think the question is how do
we break it apart i agree
heavily that we need localized solutions
i think a big part of this is people
looking after their own lives their
families obviously it would be ideal to
return power to more local levels but
then the question becomes how do we
break up the very strongly centralized
power so that becomes more possible
anti-trust i mean and that that
definitely has an impact right that
slows the train
but when you're talking about to me i
take a profoundly negative view of the
wider possibilities of technology i
think that you know in the end
technology is always about control
and
conceivably it's about a human
controlling nature controlling society
controlling themselves but that means
that the vast swath of human kind is
going to be subject to that control and
the desire for that power the
capabilities that we already have now
that you already see in google facebook
amazon
this already has momentum that you break
them up
great you've at least diminished some of
their power but i think that ultimately
long view
we've got to go down the dark dark
tunnel before we get to the light you
mean like ayahuasca journeys where
people like see their inner demons and
stuff
you know it doesn't take ayahuasca for
me to see the inner demons but now that
you mention it
we won't go there no it's bad for my
brain i think uh culture building
you know so i've had a lot of
conversations this past weekend was on a
trip was in austin by the way that was
fun talk to a lot of cool people and the
one thing i think you know i always come
back to is
you can build all the greatest tech in
the world you can vote whoever you want
to power none of that matters unless you
have culture
so you know we talk about uh
the saying i think with breitbart
politics is downstream from culture
technology i think uh is as well but
technology i don't think is as important
i know you've had you've said the the
universe ian before
but uh the issue is
there exists alternative to twitter
nobody uses it why it's cultural issues
you know people don't want to use
alternatives they want to be on the
platform where everyone is
so if you
culture is everything i'll put it that
way if we can start inspiring young
people and say these are the values that
that are good and you should hold
everything else becomes secondary as
those kids age everything else gets
washed away with the new generation so
it really is about inspiring young
people with good values is the most
powerful and important thing you can do
to fix these problems one of the things
i noticed being out of town and on the
road i was just not tapped into the
information and it was like i realized
the amount of information overload i've
been exposed to in the last two years
and how how clear things started to get
when i wasn't exposed to twitter and
then even if i pulled up for five
minutes i start to feel this negative
dark negativity and i'd see a few people
arguing and like man i'm gonna have to
withdraw that from my brain for a while
that might have something to do with the
darkness which actually isn't evil like
too much light will burn you so you need
to sometimes have no thought what was it
uh jack dorsey called twitter the light
of global consciousness
very spiritual claim he said that he was
something to the effect he's happy to
pass the torch of the light of global
consciousness to elon musk and this
concept of twitter being
something mystical of that sort i mean
that sits at the heart of transhumanism
but uh to me i you know you look at this
this argument people are having right
now about free speech on twitter which i
do think it's good that if we are going
to be stuck in what james pulos calls
the the cyborg vivarium at least
everyone gets to say
but it doesn't change the fact that
we're still stuck in that cyborg by by
varium right we were still
in a digital surveillance system we're
in a basically a 24 7 propaganda machine
that's pouring all this irrelevant
ultimately irrelevant information into
your brain and distracting you from what
i think are the most important things i
think is us here all this started with
broadcast media i mean radio absolutely
of course it was the newspapers even
before then it was newspapers were weak
they weren't as strong but they were the
most influential medium so they would
write stuff people believe it then you
get radio they say people believe it and
then you get broadcast towers television
the networks they say people believe it
now with the internet nobody knows what
to believe
i mean the disinformation expert herself
was sewing disinformation and now
doesn't even under i don't think nina
jankos even truly understood
exactly why people were mad at her
because she lives in a disinformation
bubble herself
so i i love it when
people who don't do research accuse
people who do of not knowing you know
the truth or reality and everyone's
accusing each other there are very few
people who can see more than others
because they're trying no one can see
everything so everybody's you know we're
all trying to figure things out
but i think at this point the way
technology is going
you're just going to think something's
true
and you're not going to know who to
believe or who to trust and there's
nothing you can do about it did you guys
hear the war of the world's 1938 radio
drama oh yes orson welles you're
familiar with the people i never
actually listened to it it's pretty wild
it's awesome actually i was told that
when that played on the radio people
actually thought it was real and that
aliens were actually invading and people
killed themselves some people people
would come out looking forward to true
though it was apocryphal yeah it could
have been that's like an urban may have
been high certainly there was mass panic
uh you know i can remember when i was a
young man my grandfather told me that
when the first dirigible it was like a
glow a glowing golden derigible floated
over the small town in georgia this
woman went under her bed she thought it
was you know the angels coming to in the
world and two or three days later they
found her there like you know they
looked around before they found her
there and she was completely terrified
she didn't want to come out
these sorts of things i mean you look at
the cargo cults uh you know all these
sorts of uh you could say
atavistic misinterpretations of what
technology really is that's really
common um with the orson welles story
though i think it's just really
hilarious can you imagine if they just
played cloverfield on television today
like it was a news broadcast without
telling people it was a movie well the
crazy thing is uh so i when i was in
austin i went to waco i actually went to
mount carmel where the uh that's the
site of the waco massacre
and uh you know with all due respect to
the people who are running it very nice
uh woman they did have fake news they
had the meme of what was the name
chipman the atf guy who was there
holding the picture of the burning
church or whatever which is not a real
photograph
it's a meme mocking him he was holding
his paper saying like you know ama or
something i don't know and then someone
photoshopped it to be him holding the
the sight of you know mount carmel
massacre wicca massacre and they thought
it was real
and so i was like oh actually no that's
a meme just making fun of them and
they're like oh we didn't know that so
people
deep fakes very much are impacting
people and i don't mean deep fix in the
sense that they're intentionally
misleading like
no wonder snopes is fact-checking satire
because a lot of people just believe
this stuff because they don't know
what's true or what's what's false
it's it's fascinating because i think
false information is a big problem in
fact it is one of the biggest problems
and i would dare say that my entire
career is an effort to try and debunk
false information
the only problem is it's coming from
corporate press with billions or
trillions of dollars over you know a
decade or whatever to just keep pumping
out disinformation sometimes it feels
like you're trying to knock on a
skyscraper with a little hammer a little
ball peen hammer and you can't do it
it's not going to happen but you need
specialized tools what you can do as you
were talking about you can cultivate
spaces outside of it which you know we
have those
i'm not necessarily saying the digital
spaces but that's part of it but i think
that at least half the country if not
more is completely cynical about what
comes out of the corporate press and in
those conversations on the ground and
also in the media digital media space i
do see a real hope of people having some
degree of anchoring or sanity in all of
this this madness let me pull up this uh
tweet from former disinformation zarnina
jankowicz she tweeted in a longer thread
about a piece that she had previously
published in one of her tweets in the
thread she says since this piece was
published in summer 2020 the spread and
effects of disinformation in american
society
have only worsened and become entrenched
in domestic politics as the last few
weeks of my life has have shown
this is the type of work i had hoped to
do at dhs and the type of work the usg
sorely needs to invest in this is the
type of work that i have built my career
on not a few context-less tweets and
this is the type of work i will continue
in the public sphere i said
disinformation specialist claims the u.s
disinformation board was to focus on
domestic issues a shocking admission
it really is now that she's out she's
outright saying oh all of this disinfo
was in american politics and that's what
i wanted to focus my work on
she responded i'd encourage you to read
the paper to me she said i encourage you
to read the paper that i'm referencing
which is entirely focused on hostile
state disinformation
she then responded to a few other people
the same thing saying the threat you're
citing which you've removed the initial
context to is in reference to a paper
about hostile state disinfo you can
disagree with my assessment that it
affects domestic politics discourse but
the strategy described in the paper is
the work i'm referring to
it's almost like she doesn't understand
i i would assume she outright doesn't
get it or she's just lying
the issue is
there is no difference from what she
claims to be russian disinfo and typical
american politics she is someone who has
tweeted out the russian disinformation
line uncritically without fact checking
when it turns out it was true the hunter
biden laptop story she says i i was just
quoting what the president said yes you
were pushing out disinformation without
fact checking without without any
critical assessment just repeating what
the liar
joe biden was saying about his son and
the illicit deals they were doing if you
did any amount of work you would have
seen that there are illicit dealings
from hunter biden with barisma in
ukraine and china you would know about
joe biden flying his son in air force
two into china for private equity deals
but she's done no research on any of
this blindly pushes lies and then says i
want to work on these issues affecting
domestic politics but that's out of
context when you say my work would have
involved domestic politics
if she thinks the hunter biden laptop
story
was misinformation or disinformation if
she was unwilling to actually look into
what that was as an expert on it she
absolutely was going to be interfering
with first amendment issues she doesn't
get it these are children who have no
experience who are not experts who just
think they're smarter than you being
given government jobs hey that sounds
like government in its entirety doesn't
it i don't know tim i think she did some
research she asked joe biden if you did
anything wrong his administration said
no so there you go mostly false yeah
well okay then
i stand corrected sheamus yeah you know
she said that it was a bunch of state
disinformation i think she specified
it's a lot of corporate disinformation
too we really got to focus on the
corporations trying to take over the
world right now she said the hunter
binding laptop story what did you say
was it was a trump campaign product i
believe so yeah she's full of it it's
what she does she lies she entrenches
herself in domestic politics and says i
want to focus on this but you've removed
context this is the problem with these
people now of course you know uh respect
for her responding at all invite her on
the show but she said she's unavailable
she's about to have a child i guess so
all right well you know congratulations
to you yeah i mean that's a legitimate
response as to why you can't come on the
show i'm not gonna a lot of people are
like she's scared she'll never come up
you know she's gonna have a kid
yeah that's that's an acceptable answer
i mean honestly i don't think she's
lying about being pregnant or anything
like that but uh well we don't have a
discipli disinformation board to
investigate it so without that we can
never know if she's pregnant or not it's
true what really bothers me is that
americans would get caught in the
crossfire of this or or collaterally
damaged by this disinformation
specialist hammering down on things that
they think are like foreign actors or
you know like how can you discern if
it's a 12 year old in russia with a vpn
or a 17 year old in dubuque iowa i mean
you ca they might think they can maybe
they think they do but i mean the
russian would want you to think it's
dubuque the dubuque i would want you to
think it's russian so like
who in their right mind thinks they have
the hammer on that you you look at all
the things that uh nina jankowicz is
about right and especially with the
laptop instance but but you know covid
all of that
these people aren't really trying to
stamp out disinformation obviously
they're just trying to stamp out any
competition with their disinformation i
mean i'm not saying that every
pronouncement that came out
regarding the laptop let's just say that
i think all of that was bs but
say with covid i think that to some
extent people were confused afraid they
said a lot of stupid things they refused
to walk them back and when they did they
pretended as if they were right the
whole time or if as if the situation was
evolving but at this point after two and
a half years of it it really you know
for me 42 years of it but uh two and a
half years of it i i just see no reason
at all to take these people on good
faith totally at all
totally agreed and i've mentioned this
before on the show but
they argue that the science changes and
fair enough because science does change
but if you're going to make that
admission and you're going to fall back
on that whenever you have to change the
narrative you do not get to admonish
people for posting information that
conflicts with the narrative when you
have decided that that is the case at
least for the time being right so when
it comes to the lab leak hypothesis
that's the most famous and obvious
example they claim that that was
disinformation misinformation people
shouldn't be allowed to spread it then
as soon as it became more accepted for
people to believe that they were able to
absolve themselves of any wrongdoing by
saying well the information changed okay
fair enough information changes but then
you don't get to censor people who
present alternate information it's that
easy it's that easy
and that's that seems to be what their
intent is going to be
my prediction for the disinformation
board and apparently it's still going on
i don't know what the latest details but
it's not ending
they're going to issue a statement and
say oh you know that story about uh
hunter biden and those ladies of the
night that actually came from uh
where did it come from uh slovenia
uh so it we're gonna ban it and here's
our list and then twitter is gonna come
out and be like yeah that isn't allowed
to be tweeted uh twitter uh tweeted
twitter launched their crisis
disinformation policy
where they're actively editorializing i
mean at a certain point can we where
where's is there some like ultra rich
person who just firebombed your lawsuits
you know you know let me let me tell you
guys something you know the most
annoying thing about lawyers is
i think that's a hard the worst the
worst conversations i ever have are with
lawyers
they are by definition defeatest
every single conversation i've never had
a conversation with a lawyer who's like
i'm gonna go scorched earth no they go
well you know the thing about
this company is that under this statute
you're not going to win it's going to
cost you a lot of money so in reality
and i'm like
how does precedent get set
someone challenges the law someone files
a lawsuit a court issues their ruling it
goes up hits the appellate courts it
stops
times v sullivan the precedent by which
we have you know the standard for malice
and defamation or whatever
challenge it
but every single time i talk to a lawyer
about section 230 protections about uh
you know twitter outright saying our
staff will now determine what's true and
i'm like okay come on at a certain point
they have to like stepped over the line
right
here's what i hear section 230 does not
say that you aren't allowed to edit
you're allowed to do good faith uh
moderation
230 actually protects that and then i'm
like okay which means we need a judge to
tell us to interpret the law to find out
what that limitation is not just sit
back and go i guess we can't do anything
ever yeah they've been slow to pick up
on that the last 15 years we need some
serious social media um i used to go
legislation or
law
law fair people really need to start
taking these social media networks
seriously
well you know to the extent they're a
monopoly and i think they are really a
de facto monopoly
it certainly falls under the the first
amendment right i mean if these are
really
if this consists of 80 to 90 of the
public conversation it's no longer
private corporations these people pretty
much control all of the information flow
at that point let's let's talk about
wikipedia because i've been going off on
this one i'm i'm really pissed off about
this i don't understand
well i think i do understand let me tell
you what's going on wikipedia publishes
every article under their byline
every single article says from wikipedia
right there i'm like present that
argument to a judge your honor i
understand section 230 protections that
you can't be held liable for what
someone else posts on your platform i'd
like to make the argument here that
wikipedia has assigned credit to
themselves for this article by putting
from wikipedia now if i put from tim
poole that's my byline i'm responsible
for that speech right wikipedia has done
it i've heard the argument well you
can't because it's users who compile all
of this and i'm like okay let's break
down that standard real quick let me let
me let me break down what you're telling
me you're telling me that if i create an
automatic process by which i will
publish your articles under my name
i cannot be sued for defamation
so if i get 10 000 people right now to
all add one word
no one can be sued that is the stupidest
thing i have ever think about this you
could create a blank wiki titled um
nancy pelosi
and then give everyone who logs in the
ability to add one word based on the
line let's do it let's build this i'm
not even kidding here's what we'll do
let's develop
an uh a program
where as soon as you load the browser
it uh it puts you know it it knows
you're here to cookie or something so
you get one word to add based on your
position in line
you're the first person in you get to
add the first word haggard second person
can add the second word high-heeled
shoes oh that's no
no one could be sued for defamation if
what ends up getting written by five
thousand people is nancy pelosi eats dog
if that was actually what was written
who are you gonna sue nobody wrote it
try suing five nope i only wrote
wrote one word you can't sue me for
writing one word can you this is
nonsense the person who made the
platform that allows it to go out needs
to be responsible especially if
wikipedia is putting from wikipedia
under every article
but every time i talk to a lawyer i hear
the same thing well you can't because of
statute i'm like okay get a precedent
because certainly if it's true that you
can't sue wikipedia or twitter any of
these platforms then there is no longer
any civil uh
uh civil tort or defamation clause none
of it none of it exists there's no
defamation you know what i want to
defend some defame somebody i'm just
going to be like here's an open forum
here's what we could do on timcast.com
we'll open up a comment section anybody
can write whatever they want in the
comments and then we'll just take them
all and paste them as a front page
article nice and whatever and
we'll grab a random user and we'll use
their sentence as the headline and
here's the best part only 10 people will
be granted special access to do so like
wikipedia wikipedia has special editors
who are allowed to lock and unlock pages
and have higher tiers they're given
special editing privileges but that
still is defamation proof okay well
let's make that and see what happens
here's my suggestion let's build a
system
here's how it works
it is blank
the first person to log in gets the
first word every time you load it you'll
be placed in line behind someone else
and if they don't write a word then
after 15 seconds their position expires
then you move up and you can add your
next word and then someone else can add
the next word and then you just get 50
000 people who all add one word to the
great news article that is i don't know
nancy pelosi or taylor lorenz or
whatever and then they can't do anything
about it and then we'll put it on times
square billboard okay well first of all
that just sounds insanely fun i really
want to do that um and the second thing
is that this is an incredibly big
loophole that apparently no one else is
taking advantage of and i think that we
should absolutely do something like this
wikipedia is taking advantage of it
that's that's all wikipedia is now there
been a lot of lawsuits against wikipedia
and i guess what happens is two things
they just settle right away and when you
settle
typically a judge is not going to
intervene he's like you want it's over
in fact some judges might be like you
must settle we're not going to court
with this
and then if if wikipedia comes to you
and says how much do you want and you
say here's my damages they'll just be
okay done bye have a nice day we win
you know talking about the the
technological freight train that is
social media and the current media
ecosystem i mean what you're talking
about with wikipedia really is the same
sort of thing that you see with the new
york times washington post when they use
unnamed sources or they say such and
such said this and
you know people's lives have been
destroyed by that so many times people's
reputations have been completely sullied
because once you put out a story that
says an unnamed source said this or just
simply this person accuses this person
of being a racist or a rapist or
whatever once that's out there and they
know this that's what's going to be in
the public consciousness so i mean
wikipedia is one fine example but i
would say that the entire media
ecosystem is is
it exemplifies how quickly
disinformation spreads and how little
accountability there is basically zero
there i don't think that you're ever
you're ever going to be able to stop
wrong information no the the issue is
when when it's completely automated or
when you wield institut institutional
power behind statute so twitter's
position of we're going to censor things
that we deem to be wrong i'm like okay
listen
if you as a platform i'm just gonna say
if if your position is that
you pick and choose what content is seen
or not i don't care if random a random
person writes it if you decided so this
is not the standard a lot of
conservatives think the standard for 230
is you're either a platform or a
publisher that's not the standard it
should be the standard and we'd be done
then twitter would be like we're not
editorializing anything anymore no more
algorithms because if we intervene in
any way all of a sudden now we assume
liability for every statement ever good
that's how it should be that's not how
it is because of section 230. well you
know when i was talking about uh
localism regionalism uh where you know
the kind of personal approach to
combating any sort of corrupt system
if you cultivate young people to be
critical to look at these things with if
at least a critical life not a cynical
eye you will have a generation that
comes up that's simply not subject to it
unfortunately i mean the educational
system is so eaten up with it i can
remember even 15 years ago wikipedia was
completely forbidden as a source to cite
now it's pretty much on the regular
people are you know
everything from undergrads possibly up
to the grad level who knows people are
encouraged to seek out these sorts of uh
we'll say homogenized conformist sources
uh in the public you know in the public
education system i really do think
though that independent communities are
everything from radical catholics to you
know radical hippies uh to just you know
your average right
your average your average you know right
winger with a pistol i think that there
is this really deep cynicism and
skepticism towards the mainstream right
now and if that can be latched on uh it
will take time and but in time you will
have a generation that comes up that's
able to handle this that's able to get
on top of it i just wanna i wanna i
wanna stress this real quick before
moving on just so people can think about
it
if you go on wikipedia
and you contribute to an article say on
ian and you write you know ian once uh
kicked a dog he's a radical hippie you
have made a false statement against ian
he did never he did not do that and it
causes him damage all of a sudden he
loses his sponsorship from a local you
know dog pet dog store or something
then he's like i got damages and you and
you lied about me and you know you knew
you lied
you're gonna get sued for that but if
you go on with 10 friends and you write
ian and then your friend writes once and
then someone random guy says kicked and
another person puts uh and then other
person puts a dog
no one can be sued because no one made a
statement
that's the that's that is insane
and i believe a judge would rule against
that immediately that's what wikipedia
is
you can go into wikipedia and change a
single word someone will write ian once
kicked a uh head of lettuce
and then someone can change lettuce to
dog head of dog
and they didn't say he did it they only
wrote one word so who's responsible for
defaming that's the problem with
wikipedia that's why i say
they should not have section 230
protections as it stands today because
it makes no sense
10 people all right one word then all of
a sudden no one said the word no one
said the phrase no wikipedia did
wait you can't
it's just so dumb like that wikipedia
can automate the defamation process and
then try and be absolved from it no no
no if you're listening and you feel like
you know filing lawsuits i think
somebody needs to file a lawsuit i don't
know
yeah i think wikipedia is amazing i use
it almost almost every day sometimes um
but you're right absolutely right about
that i just think about the the what a
person could do
someone can write a long sentence saying
you know james o'keefe is a journalist
and
scholar and then someone can go in and
just change journalists to um
dog dog puncher i tried to do it i
didn't say it about him i just changed
one word after hillary clinton's emails
came out 2016 or so on there about i i
tried to go to wikipedia and change it
and be like her emails implicated sydney
blumenthal you know osprey global
solutions setting up shop in libya and
immediately within like 10 seconds it
was removed so i don't know who's in
charge who's overseeing it it was it was
true stuff that i was looking at look up
you know hillary clinton sydney
blumenthal spread the global solution
emails you'll find it yeah i mean
there's there's definitely a slant there
obviously who was the uh the one of the
guys who helped form wikipedia pointed
this out that when it was formed under
the ideals of community you know just
community contributions creating this
amazing platform they were sincere and
it really wikipedia used to be a lot
better i was never a huge fan but it
used to be a lot better now it's clear
there's a huge ideological shift
may you could probably say you know it's
it's almost homogenized look at any far
left figure show me a place where a far
left figure has been in any way demeaned
or demeaned or defamed i'm not aware of
them
it's all towards the right and the
reason being clearly is that leftist
knew where to go
a decade decade and a half ago to gain
power and that's in the media i'll
actually i'll attest to that too because
my wikipedia page is fairly tepid it's
not really that bad
and that's an interesting indicator you
know i'm a fairly moderate person so
they're like you know but if you're
right-wing they write all of the worst
possible things about absolutely with no
consequence whatsoever
so something's got to be done about that
let's let's talk about other signs of
the apocalypse instead of just
defamation we had the story from fox
business biden considers tapping
emergency diesel reserve with prices
near record high
yes you may have seen the story that
there's going to be a diesel shortage
that diesel is at what six dollars a
gallon
people who drive trucks are saying it's
costing them a thousand bucks to fill up
so they don't even know if they want to
do the job anymore and then you have
over and over again these memes
particularly from people on the left
saying it's not biden's fault biden
can't do anything about gas prices it's
the greedy corporations i give you this
from uh this is from may 19th only a few
days ago but you absolutely gotta listen
to it this is uh josh hawley was our
audio right
as oh yeah it never is is it
i always gotta listen to music before
the show that's right secretary grantham
today in the state of missouri the
average price of gasoline today as of
this morning is four dollars and ten
cents
average price of diesel is five dollars
and 18 cents
and i'm sure you've seen the reporting
this morning that now aaa is projecting
that gas prices will hit a national
average average of six dollars a gallon
by the month of august
is this acceptable to you no it is not
and you can thank the activity of
vladimir putin for invading ukraine and
pulling nonsense
with all due respect madam secretary
that's utter nonsense in january of 2021
the average gas price in my state was
two dollars and seven cents eight months
later
eight months later long before vladimir
putin invaded ukraine that price was up
over 30 percent and it has been going up
consistently since
what are you doing to reverse this
administration's policies that are
drawing down our own supply of energy in
this country that are throttling oil and
gas production in the united states of
america what are you doing about it
respect sir it is not administration
policies that have affected supply and
demand how can you say that when the
price of gas was up over 30 percent from
january to you answer my questions and
it's my time madam secretary so why
don't you answer my question from
january to august the price of gasoline
was up over 30 in my state alone it has
been a continuous continuous upward tick
since then
and here's what your president did when
he first came to office he immediately
re-entered the paris climate accord he
canceled the keystone pipeline he halted
leasing programs in anwar he issued a
60-day halt
on all new oil and gas leases and
drilling permits on federal lands and
waters that's nationwide that accounts
by the way for 25 percent of u.s oil
production he directed federal agencies
to eliminate all supports for fossil
fuels he imposed new regulations on oil
and gas and methane emissions those were
all just in the first few days are you
telling me that's had no effect on our
energy
so uh yeah i think it's fair to say that
he he very much listed the policy
changes that have impacted the price of
gas and can i just point out something i
think common sense
when you have a political party that has
been screaming climate change and carbon
emissions
do you think they're the party that's
going to get you cheap gas
i mean no
if you are someone who is also worried
about climate change you're probably
happy that joe biden did those things
the repercussions are regular
working-class people aren't going to
afford to drive food prices are going to
skyrocket there's going to be shortages
of diesel
and if we if we have to tap into these
strategic reserves i wonder considering
the fertilizer shortage already what's
food going to look like this fall when
the harvest comes and ain't nothing
coming through winter is coming my
friends and
when they try and claim it's vladimir
putin who did this
here's what i hear i hear them saying
we did this
and we're glad we did this but we don't
want you yelling at us because we're
going to do it more so we need a
scapegoat
so yeah get ready for it's gonna get
worse yeah the uh the fertilizer
situation is really critical uh already
you see you know obviously what's
happening in the ukraine has really just
shut off all of that grain and then
india of course has they've cut off
their exports and you really have to
wonder in in the long run and when i say
the long run i mean in the next year or
two
where we're going to be because if you
don't have the fertilizer and if you
have an industrial farming system right
the fertilizer the the petroleum-based
fertilizers are essential to the food
supply
but you don't have food the only thing
you then have are stores now i think
america will be okay i think you know
most of europe will be okay they'll hurt
but in the third world it will be
crushing it already is i mean
you got sri lanka yeah and there's
there's politics involved in that right
some of their policies and stuff but it
is already affecting many other places
as well um i think the the us will be
okay
but you ain't gonna be happy
no and when you have unhappy people and
you have a whole lot of guns and you
have a whole lot of anger the powder
things happen look at look at the baby
formula situation
now now we're importing and it's just
it's so laughable how people defend joe
biden like look he's solving the problem
it's like bro you don't get credit for
solving the problem you made
you know it's it's if you if you spill
milk on my floor i'm not gonna
congratulate you when you mop it up i'm
gonna be i'm gonna be like please don't
do that again
mopping it up was the least you can do
this is what we're dealing with now with
the
you're going to get angry people
you know
babies is bad enough but i think we're
going to see a lot of shortages yeah i
saw an article that said that uh you can
take uh methane and break it into
hydrogen and graphene so there are ways
out of this but i people are so hooked
on the short-term oil for whatever
reason we have been for the last 40
years of my life 43 years i don't know i
don't know it's always like it's just
two years away just five years away just
like what are we waiting for it's real
simple we built a world on oil
we are now standing on the pillars of
fossil fuels
that's why we need them
you can't just take that away because
then
your your tower will fall and that fall
is going to kill a lot of people so what
can we do i mean
slow changes
build new infrastructure to hold up our
civilization with alternate energies
nuclear power sounds like a great idea
i'm a big fan of renewables tidal energy
geothermal all really great
instead it just seems like
the people who are deeply concerned
about climate change and and there are a
lot i think climate change is is an
issue i think pollution is an issue i
think dead zones are an issue but
it's it's i think the real argument here
is human experience versus
non-human experience that is to say
if you were to just shut off the oil
right now like greta tunberg wants and
just kill 60 some odd million people
because all of a sudden i mean as i have
to mention diabetics are the first to go
when the power goes out then it's you
know no food no transport nor no heating
so you really are just the the people
who are vulnerable just 60 million i
think is the estimate you can do that
but the human experience is why we're
here so you have these two trains of
thought one that it doesn't matter what
humans perceive think want it human
perception is irrelevant therefore let's
just stabilize the ecosystem and you
know that results in how many people
dead then you have people who are like
okay look you know we can we can be
better stewards of this planet while
recognizing that we are humans we
perceive things in a human way and we
want to protect
human life and what what cause brings us
joy in which case yeah just this
utilitarian kill as many people as
possible for the sake of reducing carbon
doesn't work
well you know i i differ with many of
those on the right on this topic uh i i
do think that obviously our job as
humans is to survive right that's the
the core
other than salvation let's say the
essential task of the human being is to
survive but in the last 150 200 years
the absolute destruction on the
environment that has been wrought
primarily through technology can't be
ignored and well i think climate change
is somewhat of a red herring uh it's
it's dubious as to whether or not the
evidence backs up the theory and
ultimately it's a kind of slow moving
thing what we do have in our faces right
now as you say pollution the dead zones
but really habitat loss particularly
like in the amazon or in africa which is
driven primarily by china at this point
but also the species loss i mean once
they're gone they're gone and i think
that that
the reason that
radical environmentalists are so
passionate about this and i feel very
much in the same way is that we are at a
critical point that it you know just
because there's trees everywhere doesn't
mean you have an old ecosystem right you
go to the apple you look at the
appalachian mountain range all of that's
new growth all of it it was cut down
sometimes twice 150 200 years ago 250
years ago so what you have now all over
the earth what is still green is in the
southern hemisphere and that's being
rapidly eroded again primarily by china
and i i don't know what the way around
it is but i do think that the urgency
that's one reason i'm so frustrated by
people like greta tinberg right she's a
joke it's hilarious to watch her she
makes funny memes that that swedish
death metal meme hilarious but it
completely covers up the real critical
issue
that
we are still to this day as we have for
two centuries destroying the natural
environment and it's never coming back
so we have to find some someplace in
between
but you know as it's been pointed out by
many on the right in america for
instance uh you know many of those in
the sierra club who founded these this
sierra club you could say at least by
today's standards are very right-wing
especially on issues of immigration but
if you don't have a country right if
it's not if it's no longer your country
and you don't have harmony you don't
have cohesion you don't have any way of
exerting your will anymore well then
you're not going to save the environment
and you're not going to save yourself so
i do think that again starting local i
think the equation is actually fairly
simple
people scream climate change
the world economic forum says you will
own nothing you will be happy
the people who are claiming that the
earth is being destroyed are not the
ones who are going to give you a good
economy absolutely
donald trump gives us this roaring
economy and growth that you know obama
said wasn't possible yeah well growth
means more kids more kids means
exponential growth so certainly the
people who are like climate changes
destroying the planet are not going to
be happy that donald trump was doing
that right no so then when joe biden the
democrats the party of climate change
gets into power what are they going to
do
they're probably going to enact policies
to reverse what trump did hurting people
but
benefiting their ideology
that is not a moral statement on climate
change what we should or shouldn't do on
the environment it is a fact statement
joe biden helping people
giving them a better economy giving them
cheap fuel meant they were going to eat
it meant they were going to have
children it meant these values are going
to create more people
if you are bill gates and you're like we
need less people you're not going to be
happy with donald trump now are you
you're going to want the opposite
unfortunately the opposite means that
for you at home your milk costs 10 bucks
your your gas is going to cost 10 bucks
and you're going to own nothing and
you're gonna have to live with it you're
not gonna be happy but that's what they
want for you yeah so you made a point
earlier about how people especially
people in developing countries are
really going to suffer from this and i
remember when the lockdowns were first
beginning it was estimated i believe by
the imf or the world bank that about 120
million people were going to be added to
the category of being in extreme poverty
as a result of covet 19 though of course
what they're referring to specifically
were the lockdowns and we'll get into
that euphemism in a moment but
we we see this i've seen some sources
that say after 2021 they updated that
number to 100 million after they saw the
effects it actually had and it's really
sad because that group of people has
been totally forgotten and
they use this euphemism as i mentioned
where they say you know a hundred
million people have been
added or found themselves in extreme
poverty because of covet 19. well no
it's because of the lockdowns and the
breakdown of the supply chain we know
this just look at the states in america
which locked up and which didn't lock up
we know you're going to have far more
disastrous consequences for your economy
if you do shut down over something like
this and so the left for years was
claiming if you cut even a penny of what
we intend to allocate towards welfare
spend spending hundreds and hundreds of
people are going to die but then when it
comes down to shutting down the global
supply chain
or at least the part that every
developed country in the world plays in
the global supply chain well that's
that's a risk we're willing to take and
you know if it just saves one life let's
ignore the fact that many many many
people will die all right all right
let's go there
the independent says donald trump's
civil war bombast is bad enough
democrats shouldn't help make it worse
oh oh man from noah burletsky is mocking
someone for not being as tough as their
rhetoric is not helpful if you want a
public discourse that doesn't reward
aggression so this is uh just one of the
many articles that are saying donald
trump civil war bombast or donald trump
calls for civil war blah blah blah i
love i love how they frame it they are
shocked and angered that donald trump
would discuss such a thing
from may 11 2022
the second american civil war is already
happening from robert reich okay
the conversation around civil war is not
just something trump brought up
apparently what happened is that on
truth social someone referenced uh
bakeli i think is his name um the
president of el salvador
he tweeted a great nation like the us
you know can't be brought down from
the outside has to be from the inside
someone then quoted that and said civil
war trump then re-truthed it which is
their version of retweeting which is
terrible branding by the way but okay
let's live with it and uh
now they're saying trump called for
civil war
trump is this his first mention of civil
war
because this conversation's been
happening for four years and it started
with mainstream corporate press well
it's not his first mention of the civil
war at least
it might be it might not be but it is
the first time the media has ever
twisted his words and made it sound like
he said something different yeah yeah
that's that's true that's it this is
first you know we've never seen the
media like grasp at straws to make it
seem as if he's saying something
completely different than they could
reasonably say based on a statement so
is is civil war possible do you think
it's i think it's happening it's always
possible
probable i don't know i think i i tend
towards uh imagine noise making a
statement about world war three that it
would be a bunch of civil wars as well
as a global war corporate war neighbors
on neighbors information all of it
let me tell you why i think it's it's
happening and it's inevitable um
you need to understand what what it
means in the context of fourth and fifth
generational warfare we often bring up
it may not get to the point where people
are fighting in the streets it may just
be what we're experiencing information
warfare
law fair media manipulation
in in this modern era do we need nuclear
weapons when you have the power of
propaganda well when i say civil war i
mean violence i mean it's already
happening
to some extent i mean organized violence
and and not just antifa rioters smashing
up buildings and beating people up uh
not just psychopaths randomly shooting
at people i mean organized a national
guard a governmental body yes and you
know i
i vacillate on this right sometimes when
i grew up it seemed pretty inevitable
right and then in the 90s it seemed
pretty inevitable that the country was
going to break apart there was so much
hatred in the air so much violence that
was pretty much stamped out by
the the response to 911 and all of that
sort of foment was pushed down by the
fear of the the you know nsa or dhs
picking you off and it just went cold
now it's starting to get hot again and i
i don't really see who
would be the combatants in a clear way
right you could say oh it's going to be
conservatives and liberals it's going to
be the urban versus the rural what would
that civil war map actually look like
i did get an insight on that though when
i think it was nbc published a map
of which states would pull back abortion
rights and which ones wouldn't and uh
i'm not saying that's a clear map of
what the the battle lines would look
like in the civil war but i think that's
a pretty good indication because you've
got a sacred value there and i think
that's what's
pretty much behind most of this conflict
is sacred values i think it's going to
be fairly north and south i mean uh for
the most part we're seeing abortion laws
like it's it's northern and western
states that are uh pro-abortion to an
extreme degree colorado for instance no
restrictions and it's many of the
southern states that are trying to
implement restrictions on it so you may
actually end up seeing this one i uh
i'll reference the meme where it says
the united states of canada and um what
was it what was the other one the south
was called like the southern the
christian states of america and then and
then the north was the united states of
canada and it was like california but
then up and around like nevada and then
you know the midwest what people don't
understand about the first civil war
texas my understanding joined just
because of geography
texas was like well you know we're we're
basically locked in next to the
confederacy and if we don't join them
what happens who do we trade with
how does this work if we're a u.s state
or whatever so then basically like by
virtue of geography we're joining this
new union or whatever i think the same
thing would happen you will see more
conservative states that don't want to
align with illinois new york and
california but be like what choice do we
have north dakota and south dakota will
probably be roped up whether they want
to or not their populations are so small
they may they might have a choice that
could split the country honestly i don't
really know all too well exactly how to
predict what would happen
civil wars like the u.s civil war are
rare in fact i'm not sure there have
been other civil wars exactly like it
where where multiple jurisdictions split
you know between north and south
the spanish civil war for instance was
pockets of urban and rural areas so we
may actually just see that and you will
see i mean new york's got a massive
urban
police force tens of thousands of people
but i i think what people uh
what what you need to understand right
now about what's going on is
geographic hyper polarization is
happening and will be exacerbated by the
supreme court's ruling on roe v wade and
casey
you're going to get as you already are
conservatives in liberal areas fleeing
red states becoming redder blue sits
becoming bluer and then eventually we
just completely disagree on everything
refuse to cooperate and then what
happens when
nevada puts up a border between
california or something because they're
like you allow illegal immigrants we
don't so we're building a border between
states these are the kind of things that
precipitate major conflict or how about
monkey pox it spreads and then all of a
sudden one state says we're enacting
border checkpoints between states so we
can keep out certain illnesses like we
saw with coven actually with connecticut
and new york
you guys are big on jonathan heights uh
moral foundations oh yeah i've heard you
talk about it
let's just take his theory for granted
right that human society's evolved so
that they diversify naturally towards a
conservative leaning and a liberal
leaning the conservatives obviously are
holding down the traditions liberals are
pushing society forward and through that
symbiosis that society goes forward
right forward isn't the right word when
i say forward uh i mean in a more
adaptive direction right so
according to heights theory uh what
you're talking about is humanity
essentially as certain pockets of super
organisms in which
having that variety having the the
variety of foundations to draw from in
any given problem to face any given
dilemma you have a much greater chance
of solving it because of this diversity
of perspective right if we take that for
granted what's happening now with this
big sort in the u.s and what's been
happening really for decades but
in the last 10 years it's been extreme
you're
in his theory you're basically peeling
the human organism apart you're creating
something that's profoundly new that's
never really existed before this we're
in completely uncharted territory if
that's the case now most of my
conservative friends listen to that it's
like oh well that's just a way to
legitimize liberal points of view and
push them on to me liberals love it
because it's all airy fairy and we can
all be together but i i honestly i think
that the the covid pandemic showed a
real flaw in his theory because
him and jesse graham by the way jesse
graham deserves a huge amount of credit
but
the the idea that liberals skew
primarily towards care and fairness and
conservatives towards authority in group
preference and and
purity and sanctity
i think on the surface that makes sense
but when you look at what happened
during covid you get a really good
example of how flawed that is because
liberals really did circle the wagons
and their sense of of what is pure and
what is what is uh tainted or what is
polluting
really kicked on so whatever
you know whatever real distinctions
there are to be made there long term i
think that did show a real flaw and
height actually admitted that so what i
see happening is you have this left wing
and right wing and as you mentioned you
know the right the conservatives are are
holding back the the left from going too
crazy but the left does bring about some
changes
what happened is there was a weird
budding phenomenon where the left
started to have a growth of some sort
that was ignored and then eventually the
growth just got big and flopped off and
now is completely separate from the the
the us body
so you know in in this room we've had
actual liberals
and conservatives talk and disagree on a
bunch of core issues as you describe it
but the modern left in this country is
separate
the traditional left as you describe it
as pulling us forward
is considered right wing now
because that weird budding phenomenon is
slopped off and now is no longer
connected to the existing infrastructure
that is the rise of the multicultural
democracy within the united states
versus the constitutional republic it's
it's being fed it's being given sugar
and it's growing and eventually it will
either
burst and break or it will consume
the you know constitutional republic
side of things i think it'll probably
burst because these people have no logic
behind what they do it's wild tribal
nonsense and they won't be able to adapt
properly they're not going to be able to
survive it it really is if they are
the most extreme element of change
and no tradition tradition involves
things like growing food
they don't they don't know how to do
this if you look at that meeting with
the dsa where they're like hi my name is
john he him i just want to shout and say
that you know please stop mis using
gendered pronouns for the group you saw
that that thing that went viral no the
dsa meeting everyone's freaking out they
can't stop fighting because they're like
you know someone says guys please stop
clapping you're triggering my my anxiety
and then a trans person goes
stop using gendered language and they're
all yelling at each other and it was
just it was crazy
that that's never going to function as a
system of governance those people will
not be able to grow food for themselves
don't you think they're puppets though i
mean do you really think that the people
that's not that's not relevant i mean if
you have
eight million people in this country who
believe that they're not going to
survive a long fall
sure no but i mean they're being held up
clearly
to me i think they're just weaponized uh
malcontents right like they're they're
not
the the entire especially with the trans
movement i mean this is not something
that was was you know grassroots from
them uh you know they they pushed their
way into the public square
the left used them as a weapon against
the right and it shows i think in many
ways
how devolved we are as a culture that
they got as much traction as they did
something as ridiculous as pronouns and
and whether or not one is being
misgendered as being some kind of key
issue for the nation i i think that they
use these people to hammer on us
we're not talking about right now we're
talking about a collapse a conflict
civil war they can't exist sure no
definitely
if it collapses every transgender person
on earth will immediately start to
de-transition and things will get real
not by choice no you're not going to
have access to
exactly collective surgeries or
medication but it's not even about
trance about the the entirety of
the the um the left moral framework has
no merit the the the left in this
country doesn't understand concepts of
merit or logic now i'm not saying
literally every single one of them but
if you look at their thought leaders we
had we had a tweet that went viral from
hassan who is the most prominent
left-wing uh streamer and he said
something about capitalism that there's
only four companies that produce baby
formula and that was a non-sequitur that
idea makes no sense
it's not capitalism's fault there's only
four baby formula companies it is not
for baby formula companies fault there's
no baby formula and there's not no baby
formula because there's only four
companies there's a nonsense statement
if that's going to be the prominence of
thought
they're not going to actually solve the
problem of baby formula
so if everything did go belly up into
civil war or whatever
most farmers probably conservative i
don't i could be wrong about that but i
no absolutely right
most conservatives live in rural areas
meaning they likely have on a scale of
one to a hundred
the 100 being you are a prepper
outdoorsman who can build a hut from
trees in a day and one being you are
absolute city folk
if you if you're a conservative you're
leaning towards outdoorsmanship so just
living out here in in west virginia i
know what i can eat outside a little bit
i'm not going to pretend to be any kind
of proper outdoorsman at all but i know
that i know when the food i know in the
wineberry season as i know in the paw
paws he said i talk about all the time
hey i know where to get some food i know
where the turkeys are i know what the
animals are around here i know where the
bears are i know where the deer are you
live in a city
let's say the store closes what do you
eat where do you get food you have no
idea even if you leave the city you're
going to be like now i'm in a random
rural place what do i do well
unfortunately for you you're going to
have to go out probably a hundred miles
before you get to even if you go 100
miles you're in owned territory
so if you live in the middle of nowhere
if you live outside the suburbs you're
more likely to be conservative you're
more likely to know what to eat where to
eat where to get water you live in a
city you got none of that so good luck
yeah you know uh having lived in boston
portland and you know reared in
tennessee and now living in montana i
can tell you right now he's gonna win
that conflict
right i can tell you right now who's
gonna last if things go belly up do we
need buzzfeed
when you know if the economy crumbles i
don't think we need them now but
definitely not then top 10 annoying
things that happen when you farm look at
this
the joke i made to the uh uh the the we
we have like uh a plot of land far away
uh i don't i won't say too much but
there's uh
recreational communities that double as
like in the event of an emergency come
out and i always tell them like don't
worry guys when when it hits the fan and
everything goes crumbling if you need
someone to complain about stuff i'll be
there that's the job i can do right no
as soon as you show up they're gonna be
like start cutting wood and you're gonna
be like yes sir yeah
yeah you know i think montana especially
being out there around all these
survivalist types such solid people you
know i mean
i i don't want to name names but uh
there's a there are a number of liberty
coalitions that give me real hope for
the country out there because you have
people that are salt of the earth and
they're also just completely independent
of the system should it come to that
it you know you mentioned farmers though
we're down to i think
maybe two or three percent of uh the u.s
population is engaged in farming at
least on a professional level so uh
you're talking about a new elite should
things go belly up in the land with no
food the farmers are king i just drove
through middle america on my way back
here and man the farms are huge and i
imagine they're owned by one guy or
whoever a company is small bill gates
maybe well this is what i wonder it's so
bizarre you mentioned that uh you know
an uh economic collapse right or in an
economic collapse or a land with no food
the farmers are king it's insane to me
that we don't give those people more
respect already they're i mean they're
already making all of our food it's not
like that's only going to be the case
once it collapses i thought it was a
tragedy how monsanto screwed those guys
over with their glyphosate they give
them these these chemicals to put on
their their crops and then they need to
get their specific tailored herbicide
that won't affect it because it's and
then the next season they have to use it
again because they can't get out of it
let's think about the crops old
feudalism you know the lords and the
kings would have on the land and the
peasants and the serfs would till the
lands for them
in the in in the future if there's a
collapse farmer's got guns
so good luck you're not gonna you're not
gonna you're gonna need comparable force
to come in and take it over and try to
establish something
what about air power because this is
like when i think about civil war and we
talk about borders i'm like rivers
mountains but then i just think about
bombers and stealth bombs what's that
for you well what's it gonna how is it
gonna change the game because it's not
1865 now where a river is a big deal
anymore i mean it's still a little bit
of a big deal
air power is is great for taking out
military installations but not for
occupying artillery artillery too like
i i i don't think it's going to look
like
you know what you know i thought it
wasn't going to look like the first
civil war until the abortion issue
started becoming more prominent and
people have brought up uh lincoln's
election how that led to states seceding
the slave states and i'm like what if
we we joe biden's our buchanan basically
a feckless you know pathetic leader who
you can't even call him that he's an
occupier he's the guy who sits there and
has the title so trump gets elected and
then we see all the abortion states be
like we out
so here here's a potential thought i was
having and again this is wild
speculation
row and casey are overturned
republicans propose
federal restrictions on abortion or a
bunch of red states start passing these
bills
the left gets angry
donald trump says when i get in we are
going to
federally you know ban abortion
that's what triggers a secession from
blue state saying nope we're not going
to allow that i wonder you know i've
heard it said and i generally agree that
abortion has become really like the
quintessential boomer issue i know that
young people are also really passionate
about it but the the the real thrust of
the abortion movement came in the in the
60s and 70s and now it's just this
lingering thing i mean i i don't see
banning abortion federally but i do
think that it's just one of many many
wedges that you see pushing people apart
and again it's a sacred value so it's
non-negotiable let me let me jameis do
you want to ban abortion at the federal
level yeah do you would you would you
vote for people who would yeah for sure
do you think a lot of pro-life people
would yeah yeah i do and joe biden would
veto it donald trump would then say the
first thing i'm gonna do is i'm going to
i'm going to sign the save save the
children actor whatever they call it
because they're going to give it some
name like that and the left is going to
scream and be like no i think it's
larping can i just mention one more
point in response to you i disagree that
this is a movement that's lost steam i
actually think it's gainsteam and
according to gallup it has as well more
people identify as pro-life than than
did in the 80s i'm talking about passion
not metrics right i i just i think it's
very
we'll see what happens no i don't but
hold on look the supreme court yes
enacting new bills to restrict abortion
as it is it's it's it's more than i've
ever seen in my life you know i think
donald trump's election is you know
orders of magnitude more important as
far as a social wedge uh this is one
thing but right right sorry interrupt
yes but uh
there's a strong moral catalyst in
abortion that without you know trump is
the powder cag
abortion as the spark
perhaps we'll see what happens but uh i
i think that it's just one among many
factors and and i do obviously i mean
you see from the perspective of the war
room you see these people these are
people again most of the people that
that are war room viewers are
right-wing salt of the earth people very
very passionate and i think that they
see the battle lines drawn and i think
steve bannon has identified those battle
lines and is able to articulate them in
a superb fashion to drive that forward
even with that though you know just
seeing that passion firsthand
i i don't want to die on this hill but i
i just think abortion has it's so normal
already in the culture like the
revolutionary spirit from the 60s and
70s has long since died away
if it comes to something so extreme as a
federal ban on abortion yeah that's
going to spark things off but you know
more than race issues more than economic
disparity you know more than the obvious
corruption at the center of the system
it's not about more it's about uh
needing a tribal issue to incite one
tribe
faction
you know going back to that map i mean
clearly that map
had an impact on me for a reason you do
see
pretty in stark terms these zones of
certain moral leanings uh
you know like i said i don't want to die
on that hill but i do think that uh it
will be a confluence of factors that's
just one of one among men really i hear
you i i still will just to make one more
point about this
i think that you're right that it has
been law for a very long time but one
interesting component of this issue is
when you look at uh you know gay
marriage for example and i put marriage
in air quotes there the supreme court
decided upon that about 10 years ago and
now the culture is almost completely in
lockstep with that entire agenda whereas
roe v wade was decided roughly 50 years
ago now and they absolutely have not won
the culture over and in fact it's gone
in the opposite direction and having
been to the march for life and various
pro-life events i would just totally
disagree how many people weren't that
much
oh man let me double check let me double
so what we do we have this uh from the
guttmacher institute they say if the us
supreme court overturns roe versus wade
26 states are certain or likely to ban
abortion this looks like a regional
conflict yeah so there was a a a pole a
very of five regions you had the
northeast you had the south you had the
uh heartland you had california and i
think like the mountain region or
whatever i don't know
and uh they pulled them all
the west the majori uh the majority uh
in favor of secession were democrats at
like 40 somewhat percent in the south it
was like 60 of republicans wanted to
session in the northeast it was mostly
democrat in the heartland it was mostly
independent voters i did the math i
calculated the populations of every
state and every region broke down the
percentages to get the actual number and
then correlate them to each other and
found 37.2 percent of the united states
was in favor of their specific region
breaking off from the united states to
form their own country
37.2 that is massive wow so when you
look at this from the guttmacher
institute
you can see if we do have a new civil
war it's not going to be north versus
south it is going to be
multi-factional multi-regional
so
i think i'm sorry go ahead oh i mean you
don't see canada or mexico in there you
also don't see the the chinese nuclear
submarines off the west coast
like what are we what are we joking
about here no no no never
never interrupt your enemy when they're
making a mistake china's going to sit
back and watch yeah of course if chaos i
mean it's a land grab if we go to war
with ourselves
you don't don't don't shred this place
now it is interesting though that you
point out not north north versus south
very roughly speaking it looks almost
like coast versus center look at the
south yeah i mean i mean southeast is an
exception right well the south is the
south
it is kind of funny that the south is
the side of trying to grant personhood
and then
and the various northern states like new
england are the uh
deny personhood
by the way it's hard to find estimates
on this i see one estimate saying
roughly 150 000 worth of march for life
in dc when i'm thinking about all this
this abortion topic it strikes me as
like i said larping earlier because like
if it was real chaos and you were hungry
and starving and you're the guy who was
giving you food was aborting babies no
one's gonna try and stop the guy because
he's creating stability for you and your
family it's only when you have like
enough money to start thinking about
things and what that guy over there 100
miles away is doing that we start to i
interfere with each other's rights i
think you're wrong abilities i think in
the event of a collapse having children
would be considered the most important
thing ever and somebody was killing kids
would probably be stopped it just
depends on the situation because if the
guy if there's if there's a warlord in
charge of your locale that is vicious
but he's making sure that you're going
to stay alive i've never had to face
starvation i've heard it's
you know
life-altering completely changes the way
you look at reality perhaps in the micro
but that civilization would cease to
exist
i don't know man so like it i mean just
think about it logically if there was a
tribe of humans at any point that said
we are small and starving but the guy
who runs us wants women who are pregnant
to not have kids how long can they last
versus any other population that says
have more kids you know it depends on
the weaponry 20 years bro 20 years 20
years if you have a you you have 10 20
year olds in in group a and 10 20 year
olds in group b
so that's five couples each and one says
no kids the other says oh they take
slaves they invade if they have the
weapons the the guy that wants to kill
him
i'm not talking about liberals it could
be anybody it could be any point the
point is this you're adding you're
adding things to it that are relevant to
the point i'm making if you have two
societies
negating all external factors and one
says we're not having kids or we're
going to even take a slight 1 2 10 20
we're going to reduce our population in
20 years
you know group a that has
five couples each having two kids has a
new adult population and group b that
doesn't doesn't have a new adult
population and they've aged and now
they're weak and they're the ones who
become the slaves it's a math problem
what you're doing but you're creating a
situation that has no externality and in
reality people will fly in with b-52s
from across the world and try and alter
your your equation so the one variables
but the point is this is a factor if you
don't have kids within 20 years you have
no fighting age males well you just take
slaves you can't if you're 40 years old
and a bunch of 20 year olds raid your
city get it
i i we're talking past each other listen
listen
the fact is it is a simple fact
statement not a moral statement
societies that have more kids will have
more fighting age men than societies
that don't that's it you can you can
have whatever you want both sides are
gonna have bombers both sides are gonna
have artillery and one side's gonna have
more people more people means more
likely to win period especially the fact
that they're younger people notice the
romans were were they had less people
but they took the galls out because they
had better weapons in training
so right
if you want to get specific we can talk
about who has the better weapons but in
the united states conservatives
tend to have the weapons and tend to
have the kids therefore the logic
dictates can serve if you want to get
specific yeah conservatives are
concerned about
that's the real question i mean you know
people have oftentimes said well most of
the enlisted men in america are on the
right but the leadership seems to be
signaling heavily to the left so
people have often times asked who would
fight for the left in the civil war and
seemingly it would be our own military
right but that would only be if the
enlisted men followed orders which i
think is pretty unlikely on mass i think
that they would be crushed if they if if
they had tried uh you know say post
insurrection to actually deploy the
military in a meaningful way against the
u.s population there would be a mass
defection and i think that that that
same trend would would hold forth i
really do think that it's just a matter
you've just got this ugly corrupt growth
i like your description of that this
this growth that's kind of falling off
but you do have this sort of cancer in
the society that i don't think it's a
matter of waiting it out but i do think
that the base that is in opposition we
are far greater in numbers and
in children and in weapons it's just
simply a matter of political will not to
take them out but to topple them and
move forward so here's what i think we
could see
one day
for some unknown reason a whole bunch of
us national guardsmen start shutting
down bridges in a major city in in and
outside of new york maybe just state of
new york
and then
all of a sudden on cnn they say
there is an insurrection happening in
new york military has gone rogue
they they're taking over the city
the reality is these are uh let's say
they're national guardsmen and they were
ordered um we're going to be doing a
drill we're going to need a couple of
guys you know on each of these bridges
it's the mission here's the operation
and they have no idea why they're doing
it all of a sudden the media claims
they're trump supporting
insurrectionists
regular new yorkers go on the bridge
screaming in their faces threatening
them
national guardsmen have no idea what's
going on they're just grunts they're
they're low level you know uh you know
enlisted or whatever being told to do
this here's why it's for security all of
a sudden regular people are screaming in
your face all of a sudden they're
throwing rocks at you what do you do do
you defend yourself or no
then
you have a national story
who do you believe what really happened
matt teddy wrote an interesting article
where he said
eventually get to the point where two
different law enforcement vehicles are
rushing
and they pull up to the police station
and they both jump out and they yell to
the police chief arrest that man at each
other
and then what
there was uh i think it was in turkey
a bunch of soldiers went on the bridge
the boss for us and shut it down
it was then reported that they were
staging a coup
they were then beaten flogged and
dragged to the streets my understanding
is that these guys had no idea what's
going on we're just told to do it and
because they just blindly follow orders
they would but think about this
if you're in the national guard or you
know someone is think about how simple
it is for your commanding officer to say
hey guys we're gonna uh take these
trucks we're gonna be dropping off
supplies
and then you get to a bridge and they're
like hey wait here one minute
nothing seems out of the ordinary when
all of a sudden you hear in the news
you're part of a coup and you had no
idea you took weapons or you are
occupying a bridge you had no idea you
were just holding something normal
so that's a real possibility that people
need to understand when it comes to the
military it's not about just following
orders it's about
you're given normal orders
hey guys we're doing a drill to prepare
for for a terror we're going to be
moving some vehicles uh there may be
rides this summer and then all of a
sudden you're on a street corner and the
media is claiming you're staging this is
what i'm talking about i want i like
getting away from the mud and looking at
this from above because msnbc is owned
by comcast comcast is owned by vanguard
and blackrock these are not american
companies or or not i mean they operate
outside of the law
they own the msnbc so in your experience
you've been studying the technocracy and
these people that are moving like do you
feel that they are pressuring us into
some sort of conflict
look there are many ways to imagine what
your opponents are thinking or what
their intentions are i try to avoid it
as much as possible but one thing is for
certain is that they are sowing chaos
within our population and i think that
the reasoning is pretty clear and a
chaotic population is much easier to
control and it does have the sense of
being
occupied by a foreign government but
it's it's a it's a sort of foreignness
within our own system right it's some
alien mindset that has been birthed out
of the west that is now occupying
governments across the west
you could call it leftist i i honestly
think it's a misnomer i think uh it's
some
combination of uh you know corporatism
and technocracy that uses leftist
talking points in order to push their
agenda right now
but
it's the same types and oftentimes the
same people who manipulated the right
into invading the middle east
on the basis of
very flimsy evidence that there was any
kind of threat from either muslim
terrorists or from iraq directly right
so i i think that
at the core and maybe i'm a carpenter
hitting everything with my hammer but i
think at the core of what we see and
what we we've seen rise over the last
century century and a half
is technocracy and that's the key
principle is it's the power of
technology to control people
and to control the environment and now
with transhumanism this focus to control
the inward self
so who's in charge of
creating
investing in and deploying technology
obviously elites both right and left
right now primarily left
and what is the ultimate effect it's
about control but while you're being
sold these technologies as a means for
you to control either your own life or
the environment that you're in i think
that the the
really the over the overriding dynamic
is that technology has allowed on an
unprecedented scale
elites to manipulate and control the
population below them so you talk about
you know comcast and and blackrock and
all these different you know
multinational corporations i i think
that at the core
the the sway that they have right now
aside from their their influence over or
direct control over any kind of military
or governmental body is just simply the
technology itself is able to cultivate a
public mindset
and that
again it feels like an alien force
coming in but it's coming from within
do you meditate a bit does it help of
course like help you discern what's real
and what's not i i you know i oftentimes
question if i'm ever able to discern
directly what's real and what's not but
i think what meditation does it allows
you to step back from what you perceive
and what you think you know
and see it from a distance and then come
back and be able to act effectively i
don't know whether or not anything i
know is real but i'm pretty sure
but meditation of course is it's a
wonderful way to calm the mind prayer
yeah i do clear mind i had to forget
you'll you'll have no thoughts and then
all of a sudden you'll be thinking
you'll remember that you're thinking
you're like oh yeah i'm supposed to have
no thoughts and then you have no thought
again then all of a sudden you have no
thoughts for a second and then all of a
sudden you're thinking again you're like
whoa
uh i gotta stop that thought and then it
gets longer and longer then it's 20
seconds of no thought
and
man
i maybe that's maybe that's the answer
there's no the answer but i think that's
for sure
it helps you calm down
and
well i think if you're gonna try and say
that regular people should be meditating
to calm down you've got a cultural
problem and you need to teach people at
a young age and then we just come back
to the same answer the answer is simple
have kids teach your kids your values
that's it and in 20 years those kids
will vote and if conservatives have more
kids than liberals in 20 years
conservatives outnumber liberals in the
vote and then the vote goes conservative
we're seeing that right now
because we talk about it a lot in 2000 i
pull up these studies conservatives were
having i think like 0.5 more kids than
liberals were so conservatives were
having replacement level children 2.01
liberals are having like 1.5 or 1.4
20 years later
slightly more conservatives demographics
or destiny right that's it so that's why
i say if if all these conservatives go
and have seven kids
in 20 years for every two conservatives
you get seven votes liberals are having
no kids and they're sterilizing their
kids wait till they get those artificial
wombs though yeah
i don't think we could fight out of it
but you know i think you can you can i
mean look one of the reasons that uh
there is this this kind of paranoia
about population extermination not just
reduction
is that knowledge that you know the
numbers are on the sides uh is on the
side of the traditionalists right
traditionalists across the world are
continuing to have children while
liberals are living this this very
bizarre and again kind of alien
lifestyle this alien to the planet is
completely new completely novel and
completely unsustainable you know for
people that are obsessed with
sustainability the lifestyle that
they've act out for themselves won't
last for long unless they can maybe
perfect fusion and births out of
artificial wounds because you're
absolutely right they'll be swamped by
the traditionalists you're talking about
the bill that democrats tried to pass
sort of would allow for the termination
of the baby up to nine months
there there's no reason for that unless
you just don't want the baby to live
democrats are absolutely in favor
look aside from the bill you just look
what eric adams said you look at what
matt binder said when he came on the
show there it's like do you believe a
woman should ever have a right to an
abortion elective abortion up to nine
months yes the woman's choice okay they
don't care about artificial wombs if if
they want to have a kid that have kids
artificial wombs are are irrelevant to
the abortion issue
that was a half joke obviously um but
the artificial wounds
it is a thing right they are developing
them uh they're developing them
ostensibly for people who can't have
children uh also they're real
and also women who who don't want to
alter their bodies with babies right
they've already grown i think it was
like a sheep or something oh absolutely
yes yes and they've got you know
there's always an article coming out one
of the latest is an ai powered incubator
that they they haven't used it on human
cells but that's the intention on on
human fetuses and basically it's you
know and it's one of many gadgets such
as this but it would allow without
direct human intervention this device to
modulate the the temperature modulate
the the nutrients in order to grow human
fetuses first in smaller vats than in
bigger vats you know as much as i focus
on technology and transhumanism i think
that you really have to distinguish
between
the intention and the actuality of any
of these different paradigms or devices
so like artificial wounds may or may not
be a thing in 50 years but i think that
it really does cut to the heart of a
sort of mentality like what kind of
person would would dream up a world in
which a you know a seemingly normal
family grew their baby in a vat and then
raised it with chips in their heads and
used artificial intelligence to surveil
that child in order to find the perfect
neurological base right
and that mentality is is i think really
it's a spiritual orientation towards
technology and against the human
ultimately it's not an enhancement it's
it's an obliteration of humanity and i
think that knowing that so many of these
people have this anti-human sentiment
deep in their hearts
it gives you a really deep sense of the
spiritual corruption that we see in the
country and and really in the developed
world as a whole in 30 years
republicans will be transgender
communists who are arguing for having
artificial womb babies and the left will
be metaverse childless genetic clones or
something
and the conservatives are going to be
like can you believe how far left
they've gone right if we i see if we
continue on that trajectory though i
don't know if we make it another 30
years
unless we'll be here some of us
roboticize ourselves and the machine
just keeps cloning more you know
metaverse people this is something that
i i really i wrestle with a lot what
what are the possibilities of any of
these really drastic extreme ideas on
human enhancement or you know having
universal smart cities you know having
human beings with chips in their heads
that are able to commune with artificial
intelligence how likely is any of that
and you know ultimately i come back to
always it really doesn't matter if
everyone is addicted to a smartphone and
you have sufficient surveillance so that
you know kind of anarcho
anarcho-tyranny situation where a
certain subset of people are surveilled
to the point you can control their
behavior and everything else that slips
through the cracks well you have enough
control over the centers of power they
can go
so i you know
the idea of this bizarre science fiction
universe where artificial wombs and
the metaverse has completely taken over
people's minds and all that i think it's
really important to get an idea of what
the point of reference of the society is
or at least that subset of the society
but it's ultimately irrelevant right
like you don't even need you don't have
to worry about artificial wounds that
people
who have the money are able to get
surrogates to simply pay people to pimp
out their wounds to have children i mean
that's already here well i think
conservatives would want the artificial
wombs to exist so that you can eliminate
abortion
or mortality that's a pretty hilarious
idea well
right now there's a question about uh
you know viability
and
terminating the life of a baby if it
could survive on its own if the
artificial womb exists there's no
argument for terminating the life of the
fetus at any point well you're talking
about in extreme circumstances i think
conservatives by and large oddly enough
uh have a very kind of
darwinian advantage in all of this
because conservatives really do value
that that man to woman relationship
long-term relationships marriage right
but there's and having children and
trying really hard to stop the left from
killing their babies sure
so i i don't know sheamus would you be
in favor of artificial artificial womb
technology if it ended abortion so it's
an interesting question i need to give
it some thought but basically artificial
womb technology could be good if there
were drastic cases where the child could
not develop inside of the mother's womb
i don't think it should be something
that replaces normal gestation well i
just well obviously right yeah yeah but
like if it's an argument like i'm just
gonna remove this child because i'd
rather they develop artificially i
imagine these artificial wombs would
like pose risks to the child that
wouldn't be present what if right now
and they do actually i mean the ethics
around articulation i'm trying to i'm
trying to ask a specific question sure
if right now they said you cannot
terminate the life of the baby because
artificial wombs exist
you'd effectively end abortion yeah i'd
have to think about that it's an
interesting question it's not it's not a
it's not a question of you know whether
someone wants to choose to put into a
woman's the idea that if right now
abortion is legal in the first you know
few weeks up to depending on which state
you're in
and then all of a sudden these states
say okay well you can end the pregnancy
but the baby can't be killed that's what
an artificial woman would do
i think you'd have the left being
absolutely outraged because they're like
well what if i can't afford to have a
baby it's like well we'll grow it in our
vat
right we'll hand it back to you or hand
it to someone else
i do think it is probably one of the
funniest things i've heard in a while
the conservative case for artificial
wombs uh it wouldn't surprise me if you
saw that in the
national review or something like that
fox news but uh
there are real ethical questions around
all of these transhumanist technologies
but artificial wounds in particular and
it's mostly women making this argument
that relationship between a woman and
the fetus in her womb isn't just an
emotional relationship that the woman
herself feels
all of the all of her chemicals like all
of her hormones all of her b her bio
rhythms and you know on this
more kind of spiritual plane perhaps a
direct kind of spiritual connection to
this child
dictates the type of baby that's going
to be born so you the idea that you're
going to be able to recreate that in
some sort of artificial womb is i think
pretty absurd yeah and and also needless
because you think about all of the
innovation and energy and investment
that takes when you have you know women
and men and penises and vaginas and
wombs and you know all the things that
nature has already provided
so yeah but but
that being said
when the national review does publish
that article the conservative case for
artificial wounds i'm going to be like
well
they already exist they've already grown
some animals in them
i think the only issue now for humans is
ethics
so if they existed what's the argument
for terminating the life of a fetus if
it can be saved i'm also curious with
the animals uh i'm curious with the
animals like what the effectiveness rate
is how dangerous it is to have them in
an artificial loom as opposed to just
normally developing right so obviously
i'm not asking the question of yeah no
negatively just ending a pregnancy i'm
saying if they try to argue rape or
incest or or health of the mother it's
like okay well artificial women's right
here so you can't like you can you know
for those reasons i think then you end
up having more babies
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already please would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com become a member
we have a members only segment coming up
for you at around 11 p.m let's read what
y'all have to say a very important one
from andrew r he says the egyptians
built pyramids in north america
okay
i'm pretty sure that's not true south
america i don't know i mean let's ask
the fellow for a source you can provide
one you know what's really interesting
about that i think that's probably a hui
statement but maybe not um
the the fact that you had this this
convergent evolution of the the pyramid
system and of course the the pharonic
system where you have this this god king
at the top and then the warriors below
and then the servants below that well
the fact that that evolved independently
in the new world with the aztecs and the
mayans and the incans is absolutely
fascinating because one of two things
either happened there
one you had some guy who came from egypt
perhaps on a boat or maybe traipse all
the way across the bering strait and and
he had either the the knowledge in his
mind or some sacred tome on how to
create a society
and he made his way all the way down
into the equatorial region of the new
world and then set about creating that
new world possible quite unlikely a more
likely scenario which is i think far
more fascinating is the idea that
societies human societies tend towards
certain structures
and it's it's almost like the you know
the eu social ant colony where you have
that that natural hierarchy form right
the pyramid thing is just because of the
easiest things to build stacking rocks
absolutely and and also you could say
that it's it's optimizing human capital
by having you know a god king like
figure at the top with warriors and then
the slave i mean how else would it be
but it is a fascinating phenomenon that
basically with a lot of particular
differences in essence the new world
recreated the old world
independently out of thin air all right
we got philip allen
mccracken says oh no where'd timothy's
teal tea go or did you run out of the
color baseball team is always a good
choice good sir thanks for the show so
actually this is the same shirt that was
just icing from a cake i just said no no
what happened was it was it was teal and
then tim got scared
the color all bled out it turned great
well it was uh
well a predator had come in and i had to
change colors to blend into the
background high marks on the teal shirt
i saw a lot of clips of that really
liking it i got a bunch of other colored
shirts too so there's a blue one
red one different color there's a
there's a yellow one but that's two and
cappy so we should try it out one can
you have dandy my high school colors
give them to andy or when luke comes
will make a look wear it exactly and
then everyone will wear the the
political compass collar shirts perfect
ian will 100 i don't know what color i
mean i don't know
all right
ian kinney says jack pasok was detained
by armed world economic forum police
officers this morning while covering the
forum in davos
yeah davos cops that was crazy he was
detained for like an hour and they said
he looks suspicious oh police they know
who he is
it's like jack of a seven has like a 1.5
million followers or something they know
who they're detaining imagine they were
like we're holding you for an hour and
we just now realized you're a journalist
with a camera on a table
he was like in case you get detained and
you need to rest you can always get a
pillow uh poso
so mypillow.com that's great good for
him harry toe says no luke i puke well
y'all should tweet to luke and tell him
to get here sooner
stormfire says hey tim cassandra's name
is spelt wrong on the about page on your
website it says cassandra you better fix
it now that i paid to tell you about it
nice wow dude somebody spelled it wrong
gotta fix that better fix it good catch
cassandra that's a good name i like that
thomas sidebottom says friendly advice
for all fill up your car every time you
use it you can pay for one gallon at
four bucks one gallon of 425 and one
gallon at 460 or you can buy three
gallons at 460. might save you
significant sums of money that is a good
point
all right let's grab some more
eric mack says glad to see you're using
the brave browser and sticking it to big
deck that's right absolutely big fans of
brave
amanda delt says would you kindly give a
listen to my friend's new song the
artist is ripper find him on soundcloud
and soon on spotify he is an upcoming
artist out of oklahoma
would you kindly means you have to do it
bozeman says yeah ian i missed you
no thanks man bozeman montana
i don't know i went through montana i
think or close to it then you beautiful
if you did you should have stopped by
i know you're out there i want to hit
you up
all right jake moore says have dave
smith back on after lp reno reset what's
that
they have a conference i think in nevada
soon yeah all right dave come back on
the show that'd be fun by all means
all right noah zork says monkey pox
escaped from that truck a couple months
ago it's all connected it's not monkey
pox is not just it's not from monkeys it
was found in monkeys it's gross yeah it
can be in people
so those monkeys i think were like they
were test monkeys months ago
i don't think i just got to tell you a
lot of people have been saying that
just wrong
it's not true
the current spread and earmuffs for your
kids
the current spread is widely believed to
be among men who enjoy the presence of
men yeah that's that's what they've been
saying across the board yeah there was
that uh what is it dark dark lands a
kind of fetish club in antwerp that they
take they i think three cases they tied
back to there yeah obviously all men
enjoying each other's companies i think
they might be
they should have been wearing socially
distanced yeah definitely wear their
[ __ ] masks
any kind of mask any kind of mask all
right
all right ben hickson says avi yamini
from rebel news is in davos reporting on
the world economic forum we should have
him on uh yeah i mean
he's always welcome to come on we'd love
to have him uh big fan
yeah he talks to a woman from the new
york times that was really funny i saw
that clip he posted oh yeah where he's
like
you know can you explain can you tell
people why they should trust you when
you're not here reporting on the on
davos but you're here as invited guests
and they're like no
nice yeah they're not they're reporting
on davos they're the invited guests it's
amazing yeah we were gonna have him but
he needs like passport or something i
don't know what's going on there
wrath of paul says have you heard of the
tabletop exercise from the nuclear
threat initiative written in 2021 that
deals with a hypothetical monkey pox
outbreak on 5 15 22 seems a little
suspicious
maybe
or you know
it's a little little on the nose you
know a lot of ticket i guess this is
it's a it's a big question because you
guys have all seen event 201 i'm sure
right no i don't know you've never seen
no you've never seen event two what's
the summary okay well the summary you
can find it easily i think johns hopkins
or the bill and melinda gates foundation
have it up yeah so is the simulation
that was done in october of 2019 where
the the idea was a coronavirus is
spreading across the planet how do we
fix it well we shut off as many sources
of misinformation as we can
we roll out a vaccine we shut out any
sort of misinformation on the vaccine so
on and so forth you watch it it gives
you this really weird sort of deja vu
right because you've already experienced
all of it but they were talking about it
back then well a lot of people say this
obvious right they created it but you
know this this whole thing was just them
i guess doing a public training on what
they were going to unleash but i think
that i don't know about the monkey pox
case i've seen it i haven't really
looked into it all that much but i think
in all of these sorts of things they are
running simulations constantly and you
know you've got especially in the case
of event 201 you've got these guys
basically creating all of these hammers
these carpenters creating hammers and as
soon as they had an opportunity they
started smashing everything around them
probably the same thing with the monkey
pox or or
they wanted to it could be a right wing
conspiracy to take out gay men
yeah i think
i think what happens is like nostradamus
you know he makes a bunch of predictions
then when one happens they're like look
he predicted it's like there was a guy
who tweeted something like
he what did he say he said you know on
this date at this time this team will
win the the world series with this many
points and then everyone went whoa how
did he predict it and what he did was he
tweeted like 3000 times
all these different scenarios
then when the one happened he deleted
all of them so it looked like he had the
one tweet accurately predicting it
he didn't
medical tyranny freaks me out like i
look at north korea and he's basically
leading by starving his population which
is kind of a form of medicine you know
food is your medicine and to to see
these people not in a state able to take
care of themselves they just they just
serve you know
all right gc says tim great show today
thank you for having joe allen on to
talk about transhumanism from your war
room fans hey appreciate it
coltrane says how long before woke
activists attacked churches after pelosi
gets denied communion pope francis is
infiltrator of the woke after his
response it's obvious catholic church
will fragment soon i bet well i mean
they were trying to attack it over roe v
wade we saw people protecting their
churches we saw lefties actually like
breaking into churches and interrupting
the holy mass so really yeah wow yeah
that's crazy i i at least saw one video
of that and then i saw another video of
a group protecting their church and they
were labeled nationalists when i saw
the left vandalized statues of mary and
jesus all over the place and christians
did nothing yeah that's insane i was
like oh wow i guess they don't care that
much you really have to wonder how long
it will be before
well you have to wonder how long it'll
be before they do snap but well tim was
saying that that would be the final
straw and that would be able to push
people over the edge and i was like
you don't realize i don't think how weak
the american church is it's really bad
yeah really bad well you know well also
the left spends all this time engaging
in phony fear over how terrified i am of
christian tyranny and then they just go
out and bully christians and it's like
dude eventually
someone probably will snap you attack
somebody's church yeah someone might end
up getting hurt i'm pretty sure uh do
you know trinity church
no no in new york are they catholic i
don't i'm not familiar probably not i
think they're catholic treaty church
yeah i don't know much about the facts
i i heard that they were like the
largest real estate owners in the city
trinity church is a historic parish in
the episcopal diocese of new york it is
uh
okay so it's not catholic right catholic
light yeah catholic light all right
catholic church owns a lot of land
they own a lot of land uh the trinity
church and it is crazy out when i was
just in new york some of the biggest
buildings in the city obviously not the
skyscrapers but massive churches all
over the place huge organized religion
has
could become very dangerous
you know
but uh is it not also the foundation of
basically everything that we stand on
now it is yeah the judeo-christian
morals are the organization of the
church
maybe but they fled that that's why they
came here was to get away from that
yes uh you know people talk about
organized religion uh and i i i agree on
a personal level but it's impossible to
deny that across the planet organized
religion has been the organizing
principle for human civilizations
arguably as far back as prehistoric
times but certainly the civilizations we
know of mathematics too that's a good
organization principle i mean that's
that's arguably i mean i would argue
it's better than well no religion's a
moral one well you know it's structural
much of uh what we now have is uh you
know a christian civilization comes out
of greek philosophy which is of course
was mathematical philosophy i think i
just said this i think it's important to
remember that the pure the the pilgrims
fled i think as a persecution of the
catholic church at the time no the
pilgrims they fled from england
and they were getting because from
anglicanism
but persecution well they if i'm not if
i'm correct about this they believed
that it was too similar to the catholic
church but it was it was they left
england which was angry like i love the
idea of christian like the chris jesus
christ dude that guy
one of the most like amazing humans ever
to have existed on earth according to
what we can tell about the guy but when
the church starts to tell people what
they have to do
man that's like that's so antithetical
to jesus he didn't he went around
telling people my commandments so he
said well that's all out of it it's what
the church told you he said well then
how do you know anything that he said
i don't know man it's all through the
church i guess but i mean some of that
stuff is like
you're right you're right it's all
through the churches i think writings i
think
religion was
the first attempts it was it was
rudimentary governance it was
rudimentary social structure it was
attempted science why are we here well
very early on we knew very little and we
started to you know talk and tell
stories and experience things and then i
think it's very much moral forum works
to help guide things that that made
sense like you shouldn't eat pork well
maybe they were there they were you know
contained viruses or they were they were
dirtier
parasites and things like that we talked
earlier about the uh the god king that
that pharaoh religion it's where they
like you talking about jeremy boring of
course every chance
but like the ancient pharaohs of egypt
like those that was a religion and they
believed that guy was absolutely but you
know after that like after that period
you have this axial turn right and the
period say between 800 bc 200 bc people
dated differently but you had this axial
turn against that archaic god-king state
and all of the major world religions are
in some sense axial religions meaning
that that connection between the mundane
order and divinity was broken and
divinity began to be conceptualized as
something over and above the mundane
order and jesus is not in that time
frame but he's certainly emblematic of
that so you would have like the buddha
the various rishis and seers in india
and yogans the taoists confucius the
greek philosophers plato aristotle on
and on and on
and of course the israeli prophets all
of these came about at the same time
it's very very interesting but you have
this axial turn against that so you yes
uh
obviously egypt was the carrier of
civilization up into a point but after
this axial turn you have completely
different forms of religion which then
separate the mundane from the spiritual
and also i would argue have a much
gentler approach so the the sorts of
things that i think probably don't want
to project on to you but rub you wrong
about religion in the organized sense
it's violence it's control
all held within that is this gentle
figure of jesus focus on that let's read
some more we got straight shooters says
an opportunity for tim cast is to be a
co-sponsor of women's x games setting a
cash bonus to the prize money at award
note it's for biological women yeah
disney would not want that i'm pretty
sure disney owns the x games but we are
planning events and we'll probably do
skate skate events scoot bike blade
whatever just uh
family family fun stuff we want to
inspire parents and their kids to get
involved and have their kids embrace
hobbies and physical activity and stuff
just good positive things for the
community in the neighborhoods and of
course
we are going to have a females division
for females
then we are going to uh you know i
almost think it's kind of stupid to
retreat from the women thing they uh
if the left wants to claim women means
gendered term it's like okay dude we
didn't make
women's volleyball or women's basketball
or women's skateboarding because
sometimes people wear dresses we did it
because biological females tend not to
qualify in
all gendered events
so major league sports are available for
all genders
it's just
women don't ever make the cut women have
tried to get the nfl to be kickers and
they just don't make the cut
some women have gotten close and then
it's like been really bad and there was
a college team that got obliterated and
they're like the first team with a
female kicker and then all the guys were
like really depressed and sad like they
were sacrificed to wokeness to make this
claim or whatever so um yeah we'll do a
women's event
for women and it's going to be for
biological women you know back in the
old days on the playground you had to be
afraid of the tomboy and you're never
afraid of the [ __ ] and i guess that's
really been flipped on its head
now the [ __ ] is quite the threat to
women and the tomboy well let's hope
that she can get by all right let's see
we got here let's read some more
okay what is this squawking
squawking justin chavez says
hypothetically if companies stop being
woke and actually adhere to the
constitution how would that affect all
tech platforms such as gab truth et
cetera would they fail why or why not
i need to hear that one more time what
was the first part of that question if
companies stopped being woke and
actually adhered to the constitution how
would it affect all tech i think they'd
lose i think the incentive then is to be
where the big fish where the fish are
twitter's the biggest
oh the constitution isn't prepared for
this social media they weren't prepared
it doesn't have anything to do with
social media in the in the constitution
yet so we gotta what do you mean like
they didn't know there was gonna be
corporate social media talk about radio
either
uh social media is unique really unique
it like you control your own network
and and what is he free speech like free
speech doesn't what do you mean so does
radio you could take a radio and you
could broadcast wherever you want
whatever you want kind of radio they
have like fcc regulations and stuff you
don't you can kind of ham radio it but
radio is not in the constitution that's
why i'm asking what's your point
like free speech people are relying on
the constitutional uh definition of free
speech for being able to type things on
a social network but that take doesn't
give the the creator of the network the
free speech to shut anyone out they want
like so it's confused that you can't use
free speech in this technology you got
to think
create new laws for it i can do that
right now if you want i can talk about
it i go on and on about i don't think
you're you're i don't understand what
you're saying i think free speech is
simple regardless of where the free
speech is occurring
exactly and twitter's like a private
company it's a private network so you
don't have to speak to a private network
but these private networks are so big
that they're now considered you're wrong
zuccotti park is a privately owned
public space and they kicked everyone
out through no they didn't they was
there they lost a court ruling saying
that if you are privately owned but open
to the public you must allow protest and
that's how occupy was able to exist in
the first week anyone who tried to sleep
the cops would come and tear down their
tent and kick them out and then
eventually the courts were like no
if you're privately owned but publicly
available people are allowed to speak
and do their protests why then did the
cops come in at the end sanitation they
argue that it becomes so filthy that
they need to be cleaned and then they
brought in the sanitation crews to come
and clean it the first time that the
government the state government proposed
city proposed wiping out occupy people
showed up all at 2 am and everyone
cleaned everything spotless and said aha
so their effort to purge it didn't work
because they had a first amendment right
to occupy a private space interestingly
the manhattan i'm sorry the chase
manhattan plaza which is one block i
believe to the east
shut down entirely because they knew the
precedent in this country is privately
owned spaces must adhere to free speech
rules first amendment rights if they're
open to the public so the the chase
plaza just put up barriers and said no
we're not we're not open to the public
anymore private property go away
that was hilarious
also like the public has changed because
like if you're in your computer in your
house you're not in public
well the the platform is open and
available to the public doesn't matter
if it's private now the issue is is
anybody going to file enough lawsuits
until we get the precedent set let's
read some more though
farrell 81 says james o'keefe might
punch dogs but did you know that george
washington routinely drowned puppies see
john furling's biography the first of
men oxford university press i don't
believe that's true interesting i
believe that is untrue
ken sidakova says downsizing is the only
solution quote blessed are the meek they
will inherit the earth interesting
buy yourself a small plot of land where
you can grow enough food for you and
your family and then homestead i like
the word meek jordan peterson talks
about it it's not weak meek is someone
with a big weapon that chooses not to
use it unless it's absolutely
judiciously necessary
except for when you look at the context
of the jesus and his disciples they
weren't exactly wielding big swords
were they not were they not armed
jesus does say if you he who does not
have a sword sell his cloak and buy one
yeah sell his cloak and buy that's true
yeah this is true he also says you know
and i don't want to get into the deal no
i get lived by the sword die by the
story absolutely for sure imagining some
like you know he's someone dude heard
him say that he's like
you're going to be cold
but you gotta get a sword
like modern era is gonna be like
sell your coat to buy an ar-15 yeah yeah
i mean i think it must be a really nice
cloak if you can sell it for a sword to
be honest yeah i guess my point is i
don't want people to come away thinking
that like the bible is against
self-defense or something
yeah right
all right do for you says tim you say
diabetics will be the first to go not me
a portable fridge and solar generator
generator and panel cost around 1200
bucks and will keep insulin below 70
degrees in in infinitely long as the sun
burns bright that's great that is that
is uh that is true and correct
all right
dim sum nim sum says you guys complain
about gas canada has been at seven
dollars a gallon since around march this
year it's probably going to be 9 43 by
the end of summer so i'm curious with
canadian dollars i know they're a little
different than ours so i wonder what the
typical gas price is in canada no idea
it's it's almost the same is it yeah i'm
pretty sure it's comparable
andrew says hey tim new to watching your
channel thanks for all your work i also
wanted to ask what does wapo slogan
democracy dies in darkness mean do they
lack self-awareness or have or they have
malicious intent
it means that if people don't know
what's going on they can't adequately
make decisions for their lives so i
think the slogan is true and correct and
washington post says it because they're
trying to foment darkness
they're trying to kill democracy well if
they're trying they're doing a very good
job right
that's fine you know
it's probably one of the funnier uh
ironies in the media
all the different wapo uh headlines with
democracy dies in darkness and almost
invariably the headline is in some in
some way anti-democratic
all right jersey b luciano says pilot
flying jceo testified they are 20 of us
diesel consumption and are being forced
to cut their diesel orders also
connected is union pacific and warren
buffett purchase of bnsf
it strikes me like people need to start
creating their own diesel their own
biofuel but then the government's gonna
be like no it's not official you can't
collect rain water in a bucket because
we said so from washington dc like if
there's no fuel people need fuel let's
let's teach people how to make fuel
daniel maxwell says the election of
lincoln was what triggered the
succession of most slave states the
setti the setting this uh thus setting
the stage for the civil war to become a
hot war if scotus overturns rowan casey
followed by the election of a pro-life
president 2024 history can repeat and
that president will be donald trump
and he's going to be like we're going to
do it we're going to ban a [ __ ] in
this country
you think i will win do you think he
would win yes
do you think desantis is going to run i
don't know but the uh we covered the
story last week
60.9
of voters in the past 10 primaries like
every state was republican
so i mean if you just extrapolate that
to the general it's wild this is primary
i mean
you'd think the democrat activists would
be going heavy on the primary so this is
going to be huge
this general might just be massive uh
for the republicans and then
the same sentiment around the democrats
failures these past several years the
gas prices i mean it almost might be
better if the republicans barely win so
then in 2024 they can win everything you
know
take the senate take the executive
branch take the house
clef the misfit says if dem somehow win
2024 the civil war factions will be the
federal government versus red state
governors and volunteer militias who
will be pushed to secession by the feds
florida will be first
yeah i mean if if democrats win in 2024
you have a similar issue with abortion i
mean democrats tried to pass pass a
federal uh nine-month abortion provision
and the the the law it's funny there was
a hit piece on me and it was like why
are conservatives so obsessed with
mid-birth abortions that never happen
and it was just like it's funny because
they know nothing about my actual
positions on this and it was like
because you tried to legalize it
that's it that's it that's i brought it
up because the democrats tried to
legalize i'm like i don't know
if it doesn't happen then why do you
want to make it legal if it doesn't
happen maybe it's not happening because
it's illegal that's the craziest thing
to me they're like well you can't
legally do it make it legal okay i think
that's a bad idea why are you so
obsessed with this it doesn't even
happen if it doesn't happen then why do
you want to make it legal i just i
the the it's it's ridiculous how they
try and use sophistry on this argument
the bill said a baby being viable can be
aborted
if the health of the mother is at risk
the pregnant patient abortion is defined
by the cdc as the ending of a pregnancy
that does not result in a live birth
which means the baby is viable we are
not talking about stillbirth the law
says viable not stillborn it doesn't say
we are we are removing a stillborn baby
it says you are boarding which is to
terminate the pregnancy that will result
in a not live birth of a viable baby
i'm just asking you why why you want
that law that's it i'm obsessed i guess
it's not happening but you're evil for
not wanting it
how strange
rage warrior says i saw you play mario
kart tim it's not cheating to use
shortcuts
i'd like to explain
i played mario kart against the guys
over the daily wire and i crushed them
uh-huh it was it was laughably what
system
64.
oh yeah yeah they obliterated them and
we played wario stadium they asked you
to leave because of it no they weren't
they it was really funny when michael
knowles thought he was winning
and then i in the in the beginning of
wario stadium in mario kart 64 you can
jump half the level
single move and so i did it and then all
of a sudden i was so far ahead of him he
was confused wait wait what you're in
front of me i was winning and i'm like
you're so far behind me dude you got no
idea you know what i think then i waited
at the finish line for like a minute
and then i just like tapped the a and
like hit and he's like nah that's funny
i think mario kart is the only excusable
video game and it is it is a virtue to
be able to play it well
i think that uh being able to get
together with your friends and play you
know mario kart is maybe the highest
expression of community there is other
than that technology is horrible and
should be abolished if we can just keep
mario party yeah about pulleys i mean
we're talking about everything hoes all
of it except for mario kart
except for mario kart i don't know how
we'll power the televisions but uh it
doesn't really matter no
still tech anyway you know what i'm
saying uh it is the greatest it's one of
those ironies in life that you just have
to work out you know mario kart's the
highest form of human expression
technology is evil yeah the the shell
that shoots backwards
astounding did you ever have the green
green turtle shell only matches
you know you have to discard anything
except for a green turtle shell in
battle mode i don't know i don't know it
really it builds character it builds
character i just want to mention this i
could be wrong about this because it's
been something like 20
18 years since i actually played but i'm
pretty sure in wario stadium and n64 in
order to beat the time trial you have to
jump the barrier like it's actually
considered part of the skill of getting
a level
yeah because we were wondering how the
wario's stadium ghost was so fast and
we're like you have to jump the barrier
to get that which cuts the level in half
but we got to the point where we were
all doing it we were all so good at it
it was crazy and then rainbow road you
can jump off the side i love rainbow
road oh i didn't know that yeah you can
jump off the side and float down to the
other part of it nice ian you seem like
a rainbow road kind of game yeah
seth all says first recorded god kings
were in sumeria
interesting absolutely
all right let's see
ryan says the sword is not literal it is
the word of god ephesians 6 17.
that sounds weird like propaganda that's
a propaganda it's just by a sword it's
definitely theology it's a theological
interpretation right but you know you
look at the the tradition of christian
martyrdom i i you know i'm not saying i
personally don't get too hung up on
christianity because of that because i
i'm certainly not willing to turn the
other cheek but the tradition of
christian martyrdom
basically issues self-defense in favor
of a higher spiritual principle someone
said that turning the other cheek it
might have been you sheamus i wouldn't
talk about this it was i thought that it
was if someone hits you in the face you
offer them the other side of your face
so that they can hit you again but then
someone's like no no no it's because in
roman culture they wipe their butt with
their left hand so if they smack you
with their right you turn so you make
them touch you with their dirty hand
which was like an insult to a roman
i've heard that i don't know if i said
that i've heard that i'm not sure if
that's the case but yeah yes i've
definitely heard that wait like it would
be you're you're saying you're insulting
them by making nothing touch your face
with their problems yeah it
something like they would second guess
whether they should do it because it's
like all right i don't know if i want to
go that far that's how this was
explained to me but it's i i'm not
entirely sure that's a while ago if
someone slaps you you defend yourself
and don't let them slap you again well
said it's a pagan stance but it's one
that's uh time it's time tested
oh is that it that's it
i will say that the uh the passage too
if you look at it in the context you
know he says you've heard it says you've
heard it said do not commit murder but i
say unto you if a man strikes you on one
cheek offer him also the other i think
in the context it's clear it's about
gentleness in the face of earthly
violence i mean the entire story of the
crucifixion is about a sort of physical
passivity in the face of physical
violence but obviously the the the core
the spiritual principle prevails i think
we should modernize it and one final
thought before we go
if someone slaps you a quick strike to
the solar plexus will disable your
opponent and then you will win
uh no i think actually you want to avoid
all fights yeah you wanna any fight you
can avoid is a fight you've won that
being said my friends
fight to smash that like button would
you kindly and head over to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have that
members only show coming up it'll be
live around 11 or so p.m you can follow
the show at tim castro you can follow me
at tim cast again subscribe like all
that good stuff joe do you want to shout
anything out
definitely come check us out at the war
room with steve bannon war room pandemic
also my site
joebot.xyz my social media slave leash
at j-o-e-b-o-t x-y-z at twitter and
getter and
that's it big shout out to grace chong
guys not only am i uploading a video
tomorrow like i might upload two videos
tomorrow we're getting crazy go over to
freedom to subscribe hit the
notification bell also go to freedom
freedomtunes.com we're going to be
launching on may 30th place your email
address so you will be notified when
that happened and we can be less reliant
on big tech well i'm doing that tonight
thank you
i love you guys great to be back tim
sheamus lydia joe good to meet you man
all great to see you guys again it's
good to be here and i'll catch you guys
next time
and sheamus news is very exciting but i
also have exciting news i am going to be
writing op-eds for timcast.com and i am
stoked i already have a little sub stack
that i keep and i write
various soliloquies about nonsense that
i find interesting so if you guys are
interested in some of that
you should head over to timcast.com
anyway but there's even one more reason
to do so you guys may also follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchlits
are any of those op-eds up already not
yet not yet coming soon cool all right
everybody thanks so much for hanging out
we will see you all over at timcast.com
for that members segment and uh smash
the like button on your way up bye guys
you